Okay,
so I guess the case that I was thinking
last time,
at least in part,
was that you're one of one way of
conceptualizing the fundamental problem
that human beings face is to
conceptualize it as an ongoing struggle
with complexity and complexity emerges
as a consequence of
the sort of finite boundedness of
individual consciousness and the
incredible excess of the unbounded every
way are everywhere else,
even including underneath that
consciousness.
Because of course your individual
consciousness depends on the function or
is related to the function of things
that are so complex.
You can't even understand it.
So there you are surrounded by some
things that you understand in an in an
ocean of things that you don't
understand at all and including things
about yourself and it's not obvious at
all how people solve that problem.
Because in some sense it's not solvable.
The fact that you don't have the
cognitive resources or the conceptual
resources to understand everything that
you need to understand in order to
properly orient yourself in the world.
Now obviously,
partly the way we deal with that is that
we cooperate with other people and so
that radically multiplies our resources,
credibly multiplies our resources,
so and so.
It's something to consider always when
so much of the political dialog that
surrounds us now consists of a critique
of,
of cooperative societies and,
uh,
an analysis of their oppressive nature.
Of course that's true because any
cooperative system,
it specifies a certain endpoint and
produces a value hierarchy of some sort.
Also simultaneously forces things into
that value system.
And then rank orders,
people according to the value structure
and so there an oppressive element to
it,
but compared to being naked in chaos,
generally it's better now.
It doesn't always have to be because it
can get murderous.
But generally speaking,
well look,
we're social animals.
It doesn't matter.
Our evolutionary pathway has already
taken us here and so we're individuals,
but we're unbelievably social and so
that's that.
So as far as I can tell,
we'd have to be completely different
creatures not to fall,
not to take advantage of and fall prey
to the problems with social being.
All right?
So
I think the way that the problem of
complexity has been solved,
and this is the best argument I know of
for the truth of the Darwinian notion of
evolution now,
I don't think that our models of
evolution are complete by any stretch of
the imagination.
I,
I know they're not partly because of
recent work done in epigenetics,
which suggests that you can acquire,
you can inherit acquired traits.
Right?
And when I went to university,
when I started going to university in
the 19 eighties,
that was heresy really.
Like,
no,
you cannot inherit acquired traits,
but actually you can inherit acquired
traits.
That's the field of epigenetic studies.
That and that.
That's a radical shift in perspective
because we also don't know exactly what
that means across any length of time.
And when you're thinking about
evolutionary lengths of time,
you're thinking about three and a half
billion years because that's the span of
time over which life evolved.
And so even things that don't have a
overwhelmingly market potency for one
generation can be unbelievably powerful
across time.
And then there's also the issue of sex
sexual selection,
because you know,
you'll hear darwinists continually
describe the world and the evolutionary
world as a place of randomness and
that's not true and I don't know why
they make that statement.
The mutations are random or quasi random
because we don't understand the
mutations that well yet either.
And most mutations are deadly,
right?
Most mutations are deadly.
There's a set of them that are harmful
but not deadly.
And then there's a tiny,
tiny proportion that could in principle
produced some benefit to the next
generation assuming environmental
environmental shift,
say in the direction of the mutation.
So that's,
there's a randomness element to that.
We know that.
I mean,
part of the reason that you mutate or
your cells mutate your DNA mutates is
because of background levels of
radioactivity.
And a lot of that's a consequence of
solar activity,
right?
So cosmic rays come zipping through the
atmosphere and they nail your DNA and
produce minor alterations and that's a
mutation.
And if you crank up the background
radiation rate,
like say around Chernobyl,
then the mutation rate rises.
And there's definitely a random element
to that and it's necessary for them to
be a random element because as far as I
can tell,
the only way you can beat a random
environment is by producing random
changes,
right?
So you know the idea,
basically the,
the environment isn't some static place
that's selecting for higher and higher
levels of fitness or not in any,
not in any.
It's certainly not doing that in any
static way.
And so it's shifting around randomly and
then you know,
you have a structure that's been your
species has a structure that's a
consequence of this immense evolutionary
journey and it's moderating itself
randomly within certain parameters.
The parameters being that most mutations
will kill you,
like alterations in your fundamental
form generally tend to kill you.
So they're incremental and so the
mutations are random and they match.
Hopefully they ratchet the randomness in
the environmental shift and so you can
more or less keep up that way,
but then there's additional complicating
factors and they're not trivial.
And one of them is whatever epigenetics
does.
We don't know anything about that yet.
But the second one is sexual selection.
And sexual selection is no joke.
It could be the primary thing is
certainly one of the primary things
that's driven human evolution and I
think you can say that
you think about the environment.
Again,
let's think about the environment.
So you have a dominance hierarchy and
that's really an old structure.
The dominance hierarchy,
300 million years old because it emerged
pretty much whenever there was,
whenever there was a nervous system,
emergent nervous system and whenever
animals had to occupy the same
territory,
they automatically organized themselves
into something approximating a dominance
hierarchy.
So it's a very,
very,
very old structure.
It's older than trees.
It's older than flowers,
it's old.
And as far as real goes from a Darwinian
sense,
permanent is real.
And so when you,
you can say,
well,
you know,
our burial ancestors adapted themselves
to treats and so the tree was a long
around long enough to be a feature of
the environment.
But the dominance hierarchy has been
around a lot longer than trees.
And you can think of the dominance
hierarchy both as an adaptation to the
environment,
because you'd kind of think about the
dominant Turkey has a cultural
construct,
but if a cultural construct lasts long
enough that it becomes part of the
environment and so the dominant Turkey's
part of the environment and what seems
to happen roughly speaking,
and this is an oversimplification but
we'll go with it,
is that males have a dominance hierarchy
and there's a relatively small number of
males that are relatively successful and
those successful males have preferential
access to female reproductive capacity
either because the females actively
choose the the more dominant males,
which is very,
very common or because the more dominant
males chase all the less dominant males
away so that even if the females don't
exercise choice,
which they often do,
then the only males left around that can
serve as reasonable.
Mating partners are the more powerful
ones.
And so you think you get to really
radical determiners of evolution as a
consequence of that one.
Is that
each.
I'm not talking about female dominance
hierarchies at the moment,
but I can talk about that,
but that's why this is an
oversimplification,
but what happens is that the males
obviously are selected for their ability
to move up dominance hierarchies
obviously because the ones that are at
the top of the dominance hierarchy
reproduce preferentially and so that
means the male dominance hierarchy
becomes a method of selection,
but then allied with that is the female
proclivity for choice on whatever
dimension the dominance hierarchy
happens to be arranged and so then
female sexual selection also becomes a
radical nonrandom selector of,
of,
of what,
what genetic material is going to move
into the next generation.
And so I,
I failed to see how any of that can be
separated from the emergence of complex
nervous systems and mind over the course
of evolution because people aren't.
Creatures aren't making random choices.
They're not random at all.
So we even know such things like imagine
a peacock's tail,
you know,
it's covered with ice,
which is quite interesting because eyes
of course attract attention and lots of
animals have evolved.
I liked markets like moss.
There's moss that when they unfold your
wings,
they have two big eyes on the back of
them and that's to keep birds from
eating them right?
Because the birds don't like being
stared at so they stay away from the
moths,
but so a peacock's tails is nothing but
eyes and so it's very attractive and it
shimmers and there's something about it
that's beautiful,
which is quite interesting to.
The females have obviously been
selecting the male peacock peacocks for
beauty and they have this insane tail
while.
So the evolutionary biologists have
thought,
well,
what possible utility could that tail
be?
Is it just maybe the females got fixated
on tail,
so to speak,
and you know,
you've got a bold would affect loop
going there and the male peacocks just
got bigger and bigger tales and it's
just like an evolutionary dead end.
It's,
you know,
it's a positive feedback system that's
gone out of control,
but they have done things that like look
at the symmetry and and and breadth say,
or the symmetry and size and overall
quality of the male peacock's tail as a
marker for physical health.
So reduce parasite load for example,
and it does turn out that the healthier
male peacocks have better tail display.
And so the way what the female seemed to
be doing is using some marker or some
set of markers as a proxy indicator for,
for,
for health.
And I think I think you could say with,
with reasonable,
you could say reasonable that reasonably
that female human beings do the same
thing to male human beings and there's
some of that vice versa too.
Like we evaluate each other,
for example,
for symmetry,
which is one of the elements of beauty
because healthier people tend to be more
symmetrical and lots of animals use
symmetry.
Butterflies,
butterflies won't mate with another
butterfly if it deviates from symmetry
by the tiniest amounts you can imagine.
So symmetry is a marker and there's
other markers like shoulder width to
waste with his wanton waste,
with to hip width is another,
that's usually what mail is.
Use that to evaluate females in part.
So there's lots of markers of health.
Um,
but it also looks to me like the,
the,
the data worldwide seems to indicate
that women.
So imagine that women made to cross
dominance,
hierarchies end up socioeconomically
speaking and on average across cultures,
women go for men who are about four to
five years older,
you know,
it varies in the Scandinavian countries
that's shrunk a little bit,
but not that much.
And in other cultures it's bigger.
I would say that depends to some degree
on difficulty of establishing economic
independence,
right?
Because in richer countries it's easier
to have enough economic independence if
you're a male to be,
to be a useful participant in the
process of having children.
Um,
but it doesn't matter.
Cross culturally,
it's still across an awkward man mate
across and down.
They don't care much about socioeconomic
status.
Doesn't seem to be part of their
selection method,
generally speaking.
So,
so I think that part of that is also the
ability of women to select for,
for male health,
it's something like that because it
isn't that only that because if you're
healthy and energetic,
you're much more likely to be successful
because it's very hard to be successful
if you're ill.
Obviously.
I mean,
so because the competition is just too
high and both,
both genders,
both sexes select each other for
attractiveness,
both selector intelligence,
both at select for personality,
although the different,
there are differences there in terms of
what's,
what stressed but so,
so,
so I think you can derive a couple of
things out of,
out of this and this is where I think
people are different than,
than other animals.
Importantly different is that,
so you imagine that there's tremendous
selection pressure to,
uh,
towards the production,
let's say a man who are good at climbing
male dominance hierarchies or,
or climbing the male dominance
hierarchy.
But the thing that's so interesting
about people is that we've multiplied
our dominance hierarchies.
You know,
if you take an animal that's got a
rather static behavioral pattern,
then there's,
there's a single hierarchy.
Elephant seals are a good example of
that.
So elephant seals,
the males are absolutely massive.
They're way,
way bigger than the females,
and they basically have harems roughly
speaking,
and they,
they used physical prowess as their
marker of status essentially.
And obviously size is a huge part of
that because otherwise the male elephant
seals wouldn't be as,
they're massive.
These things are absolutely enormous.
And so it's just power slash health,
you know,
maybe aggression,
something like that.
It's whatever makes them more,
um,
suitable for the kind of physical combat
that elephant seals engage it.
So,
and the degree to which power is
associated with dominance status in
those sorts of situation seems to be
associated with the size differential
between males and females.
So the more power is an issue with
regards to male competence,
the larger the bales are compared to the
females and the more likely the males
are going to have a heroine relationship
with the females.
And you see that a little bit in human
beings because men are bigger than
women.
They're not overwhelmingly bigger.
That's sexual dimorphism.
And you know,
there's some men that are smaller than
some women,
but on average men are tolerant there.
They have more upper body strength and
so forth.
So there is a power element to male
competition,
but it's not as extended as it would be
among animals like elephants seals.
So in the elephant seal,
you see maybe there's one stable set of
traits that's being selected for that
makes the males more likely to
reproduce,
but human beings,
we're very weird creatures because we're
so conceptually flexible and so what
seems to have happened,
maybe we started male,
started selecting each other for
dominance competitions for something
like cognitive flexibility and
conscientiousness.
It's something like that.
So that would be the ability to
abstractly represent the world and then
the ability to operate effectively
within it to represent yourself socially
in a way and then to carry through with
that because that enables people to
trust you.
So it's something like that.
And so that produced cortical expansion
and then women were selecting men who
are good at that and that produced
cortical expansion and then there's an
arms race between women and men with
regards to intelligence.
So the women kept up or they certainly
kept up with,
with,
with intelligence as the evolutionary
cycle continued.
But one of the consequences of selection
for cortical expansion and increased
cognitive flexibility was that the
number of dominance hierarchies that
human beings can produce started to
multiply.
Right?
Because there's all sorts of ways that
you can be successful.
There's you think about how many ways
you can be successful in a modern
culture and you can be successful in
dimensions that aren't really even
associated with each other,
so you can be successful socially that
that's what an extrovert would do.
You could be successful in terms of
intimate relationships.
That's what a agreeable person would do.
A disagreeable person would be more
successful with regards to competition.
A person who's high in neuroticism would
be would be trying to protect themselves
and to establish some sort of security
and open person would be looking for a
flexible creative environment and so
there's this multiplicity of of ways
that you can establish a dominance
hierarchy and be successful in it and if
you're creative,
you can come up with your own damn
dominance hierarchy,
which is exactly what you're doing.
If you're creative,
right?
You spin up a game that's your game and
then you make the rules and that's hard
because if you make a new game with new
rules,
it's hard to monetize it,
but you can be the best at playing that
game.
And so that's a huge advantage to being
creative if you can pull it off.
So then you think,
well what's happened among human beings
is the multiplication of the set of
possible dominance hierarchies.
So it's become very broad.
And then you could say,
well what's what's driving selection now
is the ability to be successful across
multiple sets of dominance hierarchies
and that accounts at least in part for
our cognitive flexibility.
And so that's really what a human being
is a human being is a creature that has
high potential for succeeding across a
very wide range of potential human
dominance hierarchies.
And so that gives us our transformative
psyche.
That's the niche.
That's the niche that we've both
produced and occupy.
And I think it's out of that,
that hero mythology emerges
fundamentally because I think what the
hero is,
the mythological hero is a
representation of that part of the
psyche that's particularly good at being
successful across sets of dominance
hierarchies.
And it's a very,
very biological way of thinking about
it.
And I,
I,
I thought about this for a long time.
I can't see any way that that just can't
be the case in how else?
How else could it work if we had a fixed
behavioral pattern like beavers,
you know,
you were the most successful beaver.
If you build the best damn,
it's like fine.
Then you know what's going to be
selected for it,
but that isn't what people are like and
it's also why we're so multipurpose.
You know,
we have hands.
What?
What's a hand for?
What's the evolutionary function of a
hand while you.
You can't specify that.
You could say it's something like,
well hand is useful for doing a whole
bunch of different things with well and
mouth.
Tongue,
same thing.
What are words for while it's the same
thing,
therefore very there for communicating a
very wide range of information.
It's something like that.
So were were these weird general purpose
animals,
you know,
we're not great at any one thing,
but we can swim better than most
terrestrial animals.
You know,
we can run faster than most animals and
we can certainly run longer.
Like a human being can run a horse to
death over the course of a week.
If they're in good shape,
so like we're really good at being
multipurpose entity,
like a rat,
you know,
were they call rats,
weedy species because they can be
anywhere.
They don't have a specific niche like,
you know,
there's animals down in the Amazon that
are specialized for like one tree or one
type of tree in one tiny little area.
That's not what human beings like us.
We're,
we're like cockroaches and rats,
which is nasty comparison,
but we can go anywhere and thrive and so
and so.
Being particularly good at that,
being particularly good at being able to
go anywhere and thrive also seems to me
to be a canonical element of the hero
mythology.
So.
Okay.
All right.
Now I started to introduce all those
topics because I was trying to address
the issue of how it is that we've come
to deal with the fact that things are so
complex that we can't deal with them.
And so a huge part of the answer to that
is the Darwinian announcers.
One is while you keep up with things you
can't keep up with by changing
unpredictably.
So there's,
here's an example,
you know sometimes if you're driving
down the road and there's a deer on the
road,
maybe you'll run into it and it'll
instead of jumping out of the way,
it sort of jumps randomly and then you
run into it.
You think,
well that's a pretty stupid strategy.
It's like natural selections at work
there.
But it turns out the deer jump randomly
when wolves are chasing them.
Well why would you do that?
Well,
because you can't predict it,
right?
If,
if something horrible is after you
acting unpredictably is a pretty good
strategy.
And that's basically what mutation does
means the horrible thing that's after
you always is the rapid transformation
of the environment and the only thing
you can possibly do in that,
in that case is capitalize on chance.
Okay?
So that's one thing.
So that's partly why the Darwinian
story,
I think has to be right,
because the environment does move
unpredictably and the only way you can
keep up with something that's
unpredictable,
to generate variance and hope that one
of them has drawn the lucky lottery
card.
But then there's these additional
issues,
which is that we're also,
we also seem to be tightly selected for
the capacity to cooperate and compete.
So that multiplies our cognitive
ability.
That's a huge part of it.
And then we're also,
we also seem to have constructed
ourselves,
so to speak,
through sexual choice into these general
problem,
general purpose,
problem solving creatures.
And so we've internalized some of the
Darwinian process.
So you think,
well most animals will produce variance
of themselves physically and then most
of those variants die.
But human beings have built A.
Lance built a mechanism,
let's say that's like a game engine.
I think that's a really good,
you know how there are game engines now
that people have devised their,
their,
their computational devices and you can
take a game engine and you can generate
games with it like computer games.
So I'm the game engine is a mechanism
for producing games.
Well that's what our brains are like.
Our brains are game engines for
producing games.
And so what happens is that when you
think you produce an Avatar of yourself,
you produce a fictional world,
and that that Avatar and habits,
and maybe you produce multiple fictional
worlds and multiple avatars,
that's the EU that could be tomorrow,
which is what you're doing when you're
planning and you walk the Avatar through
its potential routes and those that look
good and you keep and those that don't
look good,
you kill.
And so you can then you can embody the
ideas that you keep an act those out.
And hopefully the idea is that when you
embody them,
you're successful and you don't get
killed.
And so we're select.
We've also seen that when we've been
selecting each other for cognitive
prowess,
we've been selecting ourselves for the
ability to generate avatars out of
ourself and kill them instead of dying.
It's unbelievably brilliant.
And,
and that's really akin to the human
discovery of the future,
right?
The future is a place where variance of
you could exist.
It's something like that and other
animals don't seem to be able to do
that.
So we're very sneaky and well so far
doesn't seem to be working too badly,
although we haven't been around for very
long,
right?
I mean human beings of our particular
sub species about 150,000
years,
something like that,
which is from an evolutionary timeframe.
It's like it's nothing,
you know,
it's 2080 year old man.
It's not very long,
you know,
if you think about it that way.
Okay.
So
now what I want to do is draw a
relationship between that developmental
process,
that evolutionary process and the
emergence of these underlying
motivational systems.
It's something like this.
So you imagine you go back in time to
the emergence of the development of
nervous systems.
So there's,
there's cells that creatures use to do
produce,
motor output and there are cells that
creatures use to map the patterns around
them onto themselves.
And so those are that sensory.
That's the sensory layer,
so to speak.
Imagine sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
In simpler animals you just have sensory
motor cells.
Then they diversify sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
In fact,
that's actually what you consist of when
you're first developing in utero.
After the blast site stage,
when your cells differentiate,
that's the differentiation.
Sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer,
so then you think there's a sensory
layer.
Now what's that sensory layer doing?
Think about the world as consists
consisting of patterns of all sorts,
like maybe there's an animal in the
ocean and it's being subjected to wave
motion,
and so it's sensory systems map the wave
motion onto the motor output.
So if you look at a sponge,
for example,
sponges are good examples because
they're sort of half unicellular animals
and half multicellular animals.
You can take a sponge and run it through
a colander and separate it out into
cells in say in salt water and it'll
assemble itself back into a sponge.
So it sort of at the.
Yeah,
amazing.
Hey,
it's kind of what you do in Utero it
that the cells somehow know enough to
communicate with another to one another
to organize themselves into an
organism's.
It's unbelievable.
We have no idea how people do that
because when you're in the initial form
blast site for them,
all those cells are identical
genetically and then all of a sudden
they differentiate and they moved to
other places.
They're supposed to go.
We have no idea how that,
how the hell can that happen?
These cells are all identical except for
their position,
so they're obviously communicating with
one another in some unbelievably
complicated way and saying,
well,
you,
you're this sort of sell it and so
you're going to differentiate that way.
God only knows,
but anyways,
sponges can do this.
Now a sponge isn't complicated enough to
have the sensory layer and the nervous
layer and the motor layer.
It's just sensory motor cells,
if I remember correctly,
but what the sponges trying to figure
out what is it wants to get water
through its pores inside because that's
how it eats and so there's wave motion
constantly and so what's happening is
the wave motion is a pattern and the
sponge is reacting to that in a
patterned way.
That's a really.
It's really useful to think about what
responding to as patterns instead of
objects because we think we react to
objects,
but objects are actually a specific
subcategory of pattern and so because
they don't also helps to explain
perception.
It's like,
well,
what does it mean for you to see
something?
Well,
it means a bunch of things,
but one of the things that means is when
I look at that thing,
it manifests itself to me as a grippable
object.
I mean that that's built into the way I
see it.
So if you think about the way that you
see that on the surface there,
you can tell that it's separate from the
surface because it has a bit of a shadow
and it's a different color and it's
obviously shaped for a hand and so that
thing tells you when you look at it,
that is the grabbable object.
Well,
it's,
it's hand shaped like a stone tool would
be and so and the things around you in
the world manifest themselves as
patterns of utility that that's the
appropriate way to think about it.
You say,
well,
what does this thing mean?
Because that's a hard question.
Well,
one of the things that your eyes do,
it's like,
imagine you've got this representational
surface at the back of your retina,
it's made out of pixels,
roughly speaking,
right?
Those are the cells and what it does is
map that pattern onto your retinal
pattern and then the retinal pattern
propagates itself as a nervous pattern
loan your optic nerve,
and then that manifests itself as a
neurological pattern and that
neurological pattern manifests itself as
an action pattern and so the meaning of
the object is the action pattern that is
mapped onto the,
onto the percept.
And so what does this mean?
This is what it means.
Think this is a pay as Eddie and
observation is like wonder many one,
right?
Because I'm acting like it's one,
but if I do this then it's many y one,
two.
Right there separately manipulable
entities and so the concept of number is
in fact predicated,
at least in part on the idea of singular
usability,
but you're mapping.
It's like,
well,
what is this?
It's a key.
Well,
what does that mean?
I mapping that shape into this motion
for that action say,
well,
it's not just a key,
it's a weapon.
Right?
And so that's because I've mapped it
onto a different output pattern,
but if you think about perception as the
matching of patterns onto patterns,
it makes it makes way more sense.
You can really start thinking about how
perception works because then you can
also start thinking about unconscious
perception.
So you know the,
the blind sight experiments show for
example that if,
if you've had critical damage so you,
you think you're blind,
you can't see objects anymore,
but I show you a picture of a frightened
face.
You'll show us in skin conductance
response to it and you think,
well,
how the hell can that happen?
It's like I have to see the face in
order to infer the emotion in order to
have the reaction.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You don't need that at all.
You need a pattern recognition system
that maps that right onto an amygdala
output that produces physiological
readiness.
You don't need the perceptible entity
because you know,
you think you see something and then you
think about the thing and then you
evaluate the thing and then you act like
you do do that,
but there are parts of you that don't do
that at all way faster parts,
more primordial parts,
and so another example would be Darwin's
trick with the snake that I told you
about.
He'd go to this museum that had a cobra
in a glass cage and the Cobra,
he'd put his face up to the glass cage
and the Cobra would strike out him and
he'd go like this,
and there was no way he could control
that.
Well,
it's because the part of him that saw
the snake wasn't the part that was doing
this.
There's a part of him that does this to
snakes.
That's what it does and it's.
It's way faster than the per figure,
the to see the snake you have to the
images.
Obviously the image,
the pattern is portrayed on the retina
propagates backwards to see it.
It has to be elaborated up through a
very complex set of neurological
connections that takes time,
and so your dad,
well,
the thing that snake means this,
that's like three neurons superfast,
and so what is a snake at that level of
representation?
It's like a snake is that which makes
you do this and then you could also say
that at that level of representation,
everything that makes you do this is the
same thing,
right?
Because the same would be defined by the
pattern that you manifest in response to
that entity.
So then your nervous system is layered
very,
very.
That's sensory layer neurological layer,
motor layer.
As you become more complex,
the sensory layer differentiates into
the different sensory systems and the
neurological level multiplies in terms
of its potential number of connections.
So what happens is that you can map
patterns that manifest themselves in
multiple different ways,
in multiple different ways to multiple
motor outputs.
So you start with a fixed action
pattern,
which is just like this,
this,
the.
The sponge reflects what's the world to
a sponge.
The world is what makes you go like this
or like that.
That's it.
That's the whole world.
The sponge has compressed the entire
world into pores,
open pores closed.
That's,
that's it to states,
and then once the nervous system gets
differentiated and the senses get
differentiated,
so there's specialized kinds of cells,
then you can detect more forms of
patterns.
You can produce more patterned output to
that,
but even more interestingly,
and this is where the nervous system
starts to come into play,
that the mapping of the pattern onto the
output is no longer one to one.
You can use the same pattern roughly
speaking to British,
all sorts different outputs that are
context dependent because you might say,
well,
so okay,
I picked that up and you say,
well,
he picked that up.
It's okay.
Well,
what about that?
You think,
why you picked it up?
Well,
yeah,
I did.
Except that the pattern of musculature
that I used to do this is by no means
identical to the pattern of musculature
that I used to do that.
Right?
I mean the fact that the orientation is
different is actually extraordinarily
important.
So,
so.
Well,
my point is,
is that were sufficient nervous
complexity.
You can take the same thing,
so to speak and map that all sorts of
different ways and human beings are
unbelievably good at that.
Okay,
so now go back to when things were
simple,
so there's single celled organisms will
say,
and then they start to differentiate to
some degree and they start to propagate
and so then there's the environment
starts to shift because the fact of the
prevalence of all of these competitors
means the environment isn't exactly the
same as it was when that system first
evolved.
New problems emerge and so then there's
selection pressure on those creatures to
diversify to some degree and then the
diversification produces a
transformation in the environment and
then there's pressure on those new
entities to diversify some more.
And so you get this weird bootstrapping
process.
Maybe the environment is one thing when
there's 10 of you,
but a completely different thing when
there's a thousand of you.
Right?
So just sheer multiplication is going to
transform the environment and so then
the.
Because the environment has now become
more complex than it was their selection
pressure to produce diversification in
the underlying organisms.
And that took a long time to get off the
ground.
Like there were a single celled
organisms for a huge span of history.
I mean if you look at evolutionary
history,
the amount of time that there were
single celled organisms is far longer
than the time that there's been since
there were multi celled organisms.
It's like,
it's like Moore's law,
you know,
the law that governs the,
the increase in computational power.
You can trace that back to about the
year 1400,
something like that.
So it's been going on for a very long
time and maybe you could make the same
case from an evolutionary perspective.
It's like the flat part of the curve is
really long.
But once it starts to move up,
it starts to move up really fast.
And obviously that's the position that
we're in now.
So single celled organisms for a long
time.
Then they started to diversify and then
you could imagine,
well,
from the single cell organism,
you start getting multicellular organism
and then it ends up with this tripartite
structure,
sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
And then that starts to differentiate.
And every time there's a differentiation
that's conserved and that's these
systems,
the motivational systems he emerged a
long,
long time ago as emergent solutions to
emergent problems.
And you've conserved all of them.
I mean you've conserved your snake
reflux,
which is like three neurons long,
so that's really,
really primordial,
but you've conserved,
you've conserved function at almost
every temporal level,
so there's parts of you that are quick
and dirty and parts of you that are slow
and sophisticated and a lot of the
contents of consciousness is slow and
sophisticated,
so it can't help you out in an
emergency,
but it can do or consciousness seems to
do is take your structure,
it analyzes the world's for,
for let's say,
mismatches between what you want and
what's happening.
And then it either helps you all to the
world.
So those mismatches go away or it turns
inward and modifies the structures that
you're using.
So if you're playing the piano,
you've got this automatized routine has
very little to do with consciousness.
If you've practiced enough and you make
a mistake,
you stop and you note the mistake,
new stop,
and then you slow it down and then you
read,
you practice the new thing,
then you speed it up.
Then you speed it up,
speed it up,
and as you're doing that,
the neural representation shrinks until
you've developed this little specialized
machine and then you run that a few
times and now you can ignore it.
You can look at the notes and just play
and away you go,
and that's kind of what consciousness is
doing all the time.
You're laying out an automatized
routine,
and then if that doesn't produce the
intended outcome,
you stop.
You become conscious really because
nothing like an error to make you
conscious.
Then you do a high resolution analysis
of the space in which the error emerged.
You rematch your motor output,
your perceptions and all of that to make
that error go away and away you go,
and so your consciousness is
continually.
Your consciousness seems to be
continually building your unconscious,
your procedural unconscious,
and so to some degree the purpose of
consciousness is to make you functional
unconsciously,
right?
Because that's way better.
You don't want to be conscious of most
things because it's just,
what are you going to do?
Be Conscious of your digestive
processes.
It's like,
no,
if you're good at something,
you hardly have to be conscious of it at
all.
So consciousness is something like an
error detection and rectification
system,
something like that,
and so you can say,
well,
you can practice being conscious because
what that means in some sense,
you're always attending to your errors.
Not seems to be a really intelligent
thing to do if you don't take it too far
and collapse yourself because if you're
always attending to your errors,
you're always improving your automated
adaptability,
something like that,
right?
Pay Attention.
See if things are working out the way
that you want them to,
and if they're not,
modify your,
your,
your approach,
your perceptions.
Okay,
so you have conserved these systems and
the systems emerged to to solve the
problems of the emergent complexity and
you end up at birth with all of these
conserved systems and so those would be
proclivities that would enable you to
manifest necessary realm of behaviors in
the social natural human environment,
something like that.
So you're basically prepared for that.
And I,
I told I,
we went through what those were last
time and you can break them down into
self maintenance motivations and self
propagation motivation,
something like that.
So,
okay,
now the question is how did those
manifest themselves and that's where we
get.
That's where we can make a shift,
say from evolutionary ideas and
biological ideas to narrative ideas.
So I,
I made the case for you that you exist
within.
Within this thing,
I've never figured out exactly what to
call it because you can call it a game
or you can call it a frame of reference,
which is pretty good one.
Or you can call it a story or you can
call it a unit of perception,
but that's not exactly right because
it's more than perception.
It's really this,
it's a really what it is is a micro
personality.
It's,
it's your,
it's your personality as it manifests
itself at it,
at the highest possible resolution.
That's what this is.
And so if I'm,
let's say I set myself the task of
moving those keys from there to here.
So my perceptual frame is,
it's this thing I think,
well,
what's the world?
Everything else can be ignored.
I need to make an object out of my hand.
These keys,
that tiny spot on the table and,
and my goal is to transform this pattern
into that pattern and it's a pattern
because it maintains itself across time,
right?
It's not like smoke or cloud.
It persists.
So there it is.
There it is,
there it is.
There it is.
That's a pattern that's extending across
time.
So I have this goal which is the
transformation of this,
into that and that goal.
So that would be roughly speaking,
the goal is point b,
but you can't just think about this as
something that's a goal because it isn't
just a goal.
There's a goal which is the end,
which is the end state of this entire
process.
The End State is,
I've moved the thing from here to here.
I've transformed this into this and I've
done it using action and that's so.
That's a useful thing to know too.
I have an abstract notion.
That's my decision that I'm going to get
the world to manifest this pattern
instead of this one.
Okay,
so that gives me my target.
That's an abstraction,
but when I actually do the
transformation,
that's not an abstraction because now
I'm using actual action,
actual behavior,
and so I take this abstract micro
personality.
This is the part that's operating on
this tiny little section of the world.
I make the transformation and as soon as
I do that and other thing happens,
which is I don't need that anymore.
Right?
I moved to the next one of those,
whatever it happens to be,
and so one of the things we're going to
have to figure out is what is the
relationship between these things?
Because you're always in one of them and
they're scalable.
It's like when you're doing a specific
action,
it's really high resolution and that's
kind of where you want to be operating
when you know what you're doing,
that's where you want to be operating,
roughly speaking,
when you're trying to do something new,
but it's scalable and so that's the
framework which is constructed in part
from these motivational systems that
emerged over evolutionary history.
The framework specifies the current
condition,
the desired condition and and the
behavioral manifestations that are
necessary to make the transformation and
so you can't think about it as a drive
because it's instincts are often thought
about is drives or as a goal.
It's not correct because the thing
actually determines your perceptions.
It determines what objects manifest
themselves to you in the world or what
patterns.
That's another way of thinking about it
because like when I'm looking at this,
it,
it's hard to watch your own perceptions,
but when I'm looking at this,
I really.
I can see that chair,
but if I didn't know it was a chair,
I wouldn't be able to tell by looking
by,
by my visual input.
I can kind of see this one.
Although I really can't tell what color
it is,
that one slightly clearer.
This is pretty blurry here,
like I can't see my fingers.
If I'm looking at the keys,
I can't see my fingers unless they move
and I'm very,
very focused on that.
So what happens is that all the rest of
the world turns into a low resolution
representations that vanishes on its
periphery.
The resolution increases as as I moved
towards the central part of my visual
field and here it's sharp enough so that
I can actually see the letters on that
key.
So,
so my desire,
which I am indicating by the point of my
eyes,
is specifying the objects that I see and
specifying their level of resolution.
So you can't just call that a drive or a
goal.
It's,
it's,
that's not right.
It's,
it's the mechanism that makes the world
manifest itself to you.
So that's,
that's unbelievably crazy thing is that
the world manifests itself to you in
keeping with your goals.
Now,
that doesn't mean that you can make the
world do any old thing because it pushes
back,
right?
It objects to you so,
but still it's,
it's very strange thing that,
okay,
so fine.
So it specifies your perceptions,
your target,
the current reality and the likely
procedure that you're going to use to
make all of that interrelated,
but it does more than that.
So let's.
We're gonna we're gonna.
Look at it from a couple of different
perspectives.
So the classic
and archaic way of thinking about
perception is the world's full of
objects.
You see the objects,
you think about them,
you evaluate them,
then you act on them.
It's like,
no,
that isn't how it works.
First of all,
the world is not made out of objects.
The world is made out of.
I think the world is made out of tools
and obstacles and it's because you can't
not perceive the world in relationship
to you and what you perceive actually or
the meaning of objects.
You precede the patterns and the tool is
something like a meaningful pattern or
useful pattern.
It's something like that and so lucky
look again,
you look at,
I might say to someone,
describe this room.
Now you're going to pick.
You're going to pick a level of
description that's very particular,
you're going to pick one that other
human beings could understand,
so it's going to be predicated on on
your size,
for example,
and so you're going to be predicated on
your knowledge that that other person is
a lot like you and it has a lot of the
same underlying structures and
motivations.
So,
and that's an implicit predicate of your
description.
So we're going to say,
well,
it's kind of an ordinary classroom.
It's got 20 rows of tables that each
have five chairs at it and each of them
does have five chairs.
There's some posts that hold them up.
There's a couple of speakers,
there's a podium,
there's a screen,
there's some additional chairs,
there's a scattering of people,
there's some electronic equipment,
and so you know,
of course that there's an infinite
number of things I could be describing
in this room,
right?
Like I could be describing.
There's a lot of color variation in that
tile.
So if I look at it,
I can see that it's unlike the other
tiles because the light is reflecting
off it.
So it's got a shiny white element.
There's about,
God only knows a million different
scratches in it,
each which are unique.
I can't even really tell what color it
is.
It kind of looks like an off grayish
green.
But if I was painting it to get a
reasonable representation,
I'd had to have to have at least six or
seven shades of green ranging from quite
dark to almost white.
And that's only if I look at it from
here.
If I look at it from here,
well then you get the point right.
I mean there is an infinite number of
details in this room.
There's an infinite number of facts in
this room.
That's also why I don't believe that you
can derive an ought from an is.
It's like w,
you know,
that's the old human issue,
right?
You cannot derive ethical guidelines
from factual knowledge and I think the
reason for that is which facts are you
going to pick?
How are you going to select them?
There's,
there's an infinite number of them,
even in a constrained situation.
So merely by attending to some and not
attending to others,
you're already using an ethic because
you can't attend to one thing and not
another without being ensconced in one
of these value structures because the
value structure is what determines the
direction of your attention.
And so you can't make the argument that
you're using the,
the infinite number of facts that are
available at your disposal to govern how
you're looking at the facts you're not.
That isn't what you're doing.
It's not possible to do that.
So what do you do?
Well,
you described the things in the room
that would be relevant to other people.
Otherwise you're going to bore them to
death or they're gonna think you're
insane,
you know,
so.
Or an artist maybe because an artist
might do the kind of concentration on a
detail that I just described,
but he's obviously or she's obviously
trying to paint the thing or represented
somehow.
So it's still too of like,
well,
why do you want to know that there are
tables?
Well,
because you said at the why do you want
to know if there are chairs?
Because you sit in them.
You know,
what about the screen or the camera
equipment?
Well,
they're all usable tools and so that's
what you describe.
You described the world at the level of
usable tool or you might also say,
um,
you know,
look out for that girl who's third in
the third row.
She's trouble and so you might call out
someone if you're describing the room
because there is somewhere in that room
that if you go,
you're going to get into trouble and so
and so.
Those are sort of the things that seemed
to me to be relevant.
There are too old to move you along your
way.
Facilitators,
that's another way of thinking about
that and there are obstacles that get in
your way and there's a tiny set of
those.
Otherwise you get overwhelmed.
You're not going to go anywhere where
it's all obstacles,
right?
You don't even mind you,
you don't want to be in that place.
You want to be at a place where it's
mostly this and then then there's the
biggest category though.
This is what's cool,
this is,
and this is so important,
is the biggest perceptual category is
that which is not relevant at this time
because it contains everything you know
like when you're.
When you're writing on this,
on this pad,
you assume the entire world around you
is constant and therefore you can ignore
it.
It's everything out there.
All the transformations that are taking
place.
You turn to zero and you just focus on
maybe the space that's occupied by a
single letter.
Your whole world shrinks down to just
that single letter and everything else
is ignored.
Well,
what happens if something goes wrong?
This is the thing.
This is why this is his own port.
What happens if something goes wrong?
An indeterminate set of those irrelevant
entities has now become relevant.
That's the problem is the invisibility
disappears and so for example,
you're all treating each other in this
room right now as ignorable entities.
Roughly speaking,
you could all be blogs from a perceptual
perspective,
and if you look at how you see the room,
except for the person that you're
focusing on,
everyone else's a blob and some of them
are virtually invisible blocks and
that's fine because they're.
You're adequately represented as a blob
of less.
You do something that disturbs the
ongoing flow of goal directed action.
Just like the gorilla thing,
right?
So
the damn gorilla was invisible because
it didn't get in the way.
Even though you'd think.
Of course you'd see a gorilla.
It's like everything that doesn't get in
the way is invisible except for that
small fraction of things that you can
use for your purpose and that's how you
perceive.
So it's so mind boggling that because it
puts perception into the realm of
ethics,
it isn't what you'd expect.
You see what you're aiming at and you
know that you know that you're standing
on a street corner and you look up and
soon there's 10 advanced chimpanzees
like you right beside you looking up to
see what the hell it is that you're
aiming at because they assume just by
watching you that if you're focusing
your perception on something and you're
fixated on it,
that it's relevant and important.
It's tool like or maybe obstacle like
it's relevant for some reason and so we
live in a landscape of relevance and
that's a mind.
To me that's an absolutely mind boggling
idea because that is way different than
living in a landscape of facts.
It is not the same thing even a little
bit and there are philosophers who've
pursued that idea quite well.
I would say to quite an incredible
degree.
High degree is probably the one who's
done that more than anyone else,
but the the 19th century pragmatist,
we're very interested in that as well,
but the because you think hold the
classic scientific ideas,
something like you perceive the universe
of facts and derive conclusions and act.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You perceive a landscape of pre
categorized relevance that's dependent
on your ethic.
Jesus.
It's so peculiar that and so that brings
up real questions like what ethic best
structures,
your perceptions.
Well that is an interest.
That is the interesting ideas as far as
I'm concerned.
Okay,
so.
So then we can make this a little bit
more interesting I think is the right
way of thinking about it.
Okay,
well,
so you've got tools and obstacles but
they're not dead.
That's the other thing because we're in
an ethical landscape because we're in a
motivated landscape.
Whether something is a tool or an
obstacle actually matters to you and we
could actually define matter.
Matter is a weird word because there
are.
There's matter and then there's the
things that matter and you could say the
world is made out of matter or you could
say that the world is made out of the
things that matter and I would say you
act like the world is made out of things
that matter.
You might say,
I don't believe that.
I believe it's made out of matter,
but no you don't because that's not how
you act.
It might be what you say you do,
but it is not what you do.
So why did things matter?
Well,
first of all,
irrelevant things don't matter and thank
God for that,
right?
Because if everything mattered,
it's while you're either you're either
in the midst of an Lsd trip or you're
schizophrenic or you're in real serious
trouble,
so you want most things to be
irrelevant.
Now that's kind of dull and takes the
glory and the glamor out of the world,
but from a cognitive perspective,
it's definitely an advantage.
So irrelevancy,
man,
that's critical and a huge amount of
what you have done is learned
irrelevance.
It's the basis of your cognitive
knowledge is learned irrelevance.
What to ignore.
Okay,
fine.
So that's that Zeros things out to turn
most of the world into zero.
Well then you have this small subset of
things that are beneficial to you that
you can use for the purposes of your
current operation,
which we'll define in more detail.
You can use that for the purposes of
your current job,
your current endeavor,
and then you have obstacles and so for
example,
if I'm,
if I'm late for class,
so I'm in a particular state of mind and
I walk in here and I see that I'm going
to get a little burst of negative
emotion,
it's irritation and the reason for that
is that is not a recycling bin.
Then it's an obstacle that some dimwit
left there just to annoy me and I mean,
you know what I mean?
That's how you react to the world in a
situation like that.
It's like it's not a recycling bin.
If it's here and I don't want to stand
there,
then it's a recycling bin.
If it's there,
it's an obstacle and as soon as I look
at it,
it isn't that I see it and then get
annoyed.
It's that annoyance is part of the
perception because it's an obstacle in
my pathway.
Then the emotion comes along with the
perception.
It's not laid on top of it.
It's not,
oh,
that's A.
I don't think that's a recycling bin
that's in the wrong place.
Now.
It's in my way.
I should be annoyed.
That isn't what happens is the
annoyance.
My suspicions are that the dam annoyance
is faster than the object perception
because it's a more primordial circuit,
so you actually.
That's now.
There's a great book if you're
interested in this sort of thing.
There's a great book called an
ecological approach to visual
perception,
which was written by a guy named Gibson
back in the seventies and it's
brilliant.
He,
his fundamental conclusion is,
I think wrong,
but it doesn't matter that the book is
not only brilliant because see,
he was the guy that came up with the
idea of affordance and an affordance is
something that affords some utility in
that can be positive or negative and he
thought about the world as being full of
furniture,
roughly speaking,
something like that.
And then what you saw,
what you perceived directly was the
affordance and so he imagined the visual
cliff experiment.
So let's say I put a piece of glass over
top of this,
the space between these two tables,
no chair there,
and I take a duck and I put the dark
here in the duck,
walks out on the glass,
the duck doesn't care,
it will just walk out and the glass
wall,
it's an aquatic animal and if there's
depth underneath that,
it doesn't really bother a duck.
But if you put a human infant on,
they're old enough to crawl,
the human infant will look over it and
that's not going on that glass.
And you might say,
well what is it c?
And you could say it sees a space
between the two tables and infers that
it might fall,
but it's like eight months old.
Like,
what the hell is it's inferring that no,
it's not.
It sees a place to fall off of.
And that's,
that's Gibson's fundamental point is
that you don't see a cliff.
You see a falling off place.
And of course why wouldn't you see that?
Because if that isn't what you saw,
you wouldn't be here because what of
your dopey ancestors would've wandered
off the cliff and died?
The ones that saw a falling off place,
they just stayed away from that.
And you know if you have vertigo and
even if you don't,
if you're up on the 35th floor of an
apartment building and you walk out onto
the balcony,
it's really interesting to notice your
perception because you might think,
well,
you see the space and you become afraid.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You walk closer to it in your body.
You're.
You perceive the damn thing with your
body.
You can also see it,
but you perceive it with your body.
It's like,
don't go there.
Don't go any closer and your whole.
There's an automatic mapping of that
place onto do this.
Go away from there and that's underneath
and faster than the APP.
The actual quote,
conscious object perception.
So anyways,
the other thing about Gibson's book that
I love is he is so clear that guy,
he's such a good writer because he takes
you through a very complex argument.
But just a pristine example of
reasoning.
It's the whole book is reasoning.
It's brilliant.
Brilliant.
So anyways,
so if you want some background on that
idea,
the idea of perception of utility,
let's say that's a great place to look,
but it's also we're thinking about it
from a biological perspective because of
bloody well,
of course you're going to see the world
as what matters because you're the sort
of creature that cares about what
matters mostly because you don't want to
die.
So you can't remove the fact that you
don't want to die from your perception.
Well,
if you did,
while you can imagine what would happen
you know,
you,
you do something like wander off a
falling off place and that would be the
end of view.
So it's built into your damn
perceptions.
And so it's built into the facts that
you see because there's an infinite
number of facts.
And so even just selecting the facts,
that's an ethical issue.
So it's actually matters practically
too,
because one of the things that I've come
to understand about political arguments
is,
well say people say,
well,
you know,
the,
the person on the other side of the
ideological continuum has different
opinions than I do.
It's like,
no,
they don't.
Or maybe they do,
but they don't see the same facts
because the filter they use to select
from among the infinite number of
available facts preferentially presents
them with the facts that are relevant to
them and that's already built into their
ethic.
And so one of the horrible things about
political discussions is that you're
actually having a discussion about what
the facts are.
You say,
well the facts are the same for
everyone.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like saying I have an infinite
library of books and you can come into
it.
It's like,
well,
you're going to pick out the same book.
Seems highly improbable.
And that's the problem with facts.
It's like there's,
there's a lot of them.
You know what you try to do something
like untangled the Israel Palestine
conflict.
I mean,
one of the things you just to start with
is like,
okay,
how far back you're going to go?
Well,
I would say it depends on what argument
you want to make.
You know,
if you want to make argument a,
you go back 100 years.
If you want to make our B go back 3000
years and then you could have an
argument about which timescale you
should use,
but it's not like it's obvious.
You know,
is it 10 years?
Is it one year?
Is it six months?
Like is it's not 3000 years.
Is it 2,999
years?
Like where are the borders of relevancy?
When you're laying out the landscape of
the argument,
God only knows it's intractable
and you know partly the way your
temperament solves that problem because
it does is say,
well,
create a creature like you with your
temperament preferentially attends to
this set of facts and that'll work
because attending to that sort of fact
is likely to produce a reasonable
outcome for you in most circumstances.
And it's a way that you simplify the
world and make a tremendous amount of
the irrelevant a priority filters.
Okay,
good.
Now the next cool thing.
What happens when you see a tool?
You're happy.
What tabs?
When you see an obstacle,
you're unhappy and they're now you
understand emotions.
And that's so.
That doesn't take much.
That's once you've got this initial
framework,
it's like,
okay,
well what's an emotion for positive?
Move forward?
Negative.
Get Away indeterminant.
Stop.
That's anxiety.
You're not.
You're not where you think you are.
Your map isn't producing the desired
outcome.
It's wrong.
What should you do?
You don't know.
Stop.
Because if you don't know where to go,
there's no point in going anywhere.
And then one,
prepare.
That's anxiety.
Start prepare.
While people hate that,
because,
well,
for obvious reasons,
prepare for what?
Everything.
Yeah,
very,
very demanding.
Psychophysiological.
And that's also something that's really
worth knowing.
It's like anxiety isn't just a
psychological state that's unpleasant.
It's like you're revved up and you're
burning resources like mad and you're in
a biochemical state such that that's
optimized for quick
action,
but it's toxic.
If you inhabit it for any length of
time,
so not knowing what to do,
that is not good and it isn't just that
it makes you feel bad,
it hurts you,
it damages you,
it can kill you,
it'll make you age,
it'll make you fat,
it'll give you diabetes,
it'll suppress your immune system so
you're more likely to develop cancer.
It'll damage your brain,
your hippocampus.
It'll increase the probability that you
have Alzheimer's.
It's like it's no joke that it's you're
running your machinery faster than you
can replenish it,
so it's not a state that you can be in
it.
It's not a state you can tolerate
because it's anxious.
Anxiety,
it's anxious,
but it's also not a state you can live
in and so I don't know where I am means
everything's relevant and I have to ramp
up my capacity for auction to deal with
that.
Bad people do not like that.
We do not like not to be where we think
we are.
We really,
really,
really don't like that and we structure
almost all over environment's
constantly,
so that never happens.
We're all dressed the same with tiny,
tiny variations.
You know,
we all follow the same traffic laws,
everybody's behaving according to the
appropriate code in this room and
everyone in this building is doing the
same thing.
It's like we're doing everything we can
to make sure that everyone knows exactly
where they are and what they're doing
all the time,
and that's because when we're in that
state,
we can advance cautiously using positive
things and maintain a modicum of
positive emotion.
That's what we're basically trying to
do.
Okay,
so you want to set up your world so that
you're surrounded by things that move
you along your way,
that obstacles are minimized and that
almost everything can be ignored.
Okay,
so emotion,
positive emotion.
That's dopaminergic,
that's incentive reward.
You experience it in relationship to a
goal because you know most of the time
when you talk to behavioral
psychologists,
they'll tell you rewarding reward is a
satiation consequence.
You're hungry,
you get a piece of food that's
rewarding.
It's like that's,
that's conservatory reward,
and that shuts down the motivational
system.
It's say it's satiating.
It makes you satisfied.
That's not the same as incentive reward.
Incentive reward says,
come this way.
Come this way,
good things are over here,
and that's dopaminergic and that's the
kind of reward people really like.
We live for that.
So when you talk about positive meaning
in your life,
this is an oversimplification,
but a tremendous amount of that is
incentive reward.
You're in a goal directed structure to
value structure.
It's,
let's say it's fairly well developed
because you're sophisticated.
Everything you do is linked to something
else.
You move ahead,
it works,
gets you move ahead at works.
Yes,
and it's that constant moving ahead and
the validation of the frame that makes
your life meaningful and so that also
means no value system,
no positive emotion,
which is another thing that's so much
worth knowing.
You know the postmodernists complaint
about value systems constantly and they
say,
well,
the problem with a value system is that
it includes some people,
winners and excludes other people.
Losers sick.
Yes,
that's true.
What's the answer?
Flatten the value system.
So there's no losers.
Find new winners either and if there's
no.
If the value system is flat,
there's no point b,
what the hell are you going to do?
Where's your positive emotion?
You had nothing to.
You're going to wander around being
happy that the value system is flat.
It's like,
no,
you're not.
Because when you flatten out value
systems,
you don't get rid of suffering because
you can't.
All you get rid of is the possibility of
positive emotion and that is not a good
solution.
So then you leave people with nothing
but negative emotion.
It's so naive.
Okay,
so good.
So now we know you're going from point a
to point b.
you're doing that with an action.
If,
if things are working out,
if you see facilitators along the way
that you can utilize your,
you,
you get to kick a positive emotion.
You know when you can.
You can even see that calibrated like
let's say you do better than expected on
a test.
Yes.
It's like that's better than doing as
well as you expected because what the
message is is that not only am I moving
towards my desired goal,
but I'm moving along faster and with
less effort than I thought.
It's like bang,
positive reinforcement,
right?
You think,
yes,
well that's it.
That's meaning,
that's a big chunk of meaning and so a
really meaningful event is one that gets
you to the next step and simultaneously
increases the probability that you're
going to get to all the steps after
that.
That's like a maximally meaningful
event.
So you know,
you get a,
you're opening an envelope about whether
or not you got into medical school.
It's like you're going like this,
right?
Why?
Why are you shaking?
It's an envelope.
No,
it's not.
It's a portal,
right?
It's a portal and what's in that
envelope either puts you that way into
one world or that way into another and
you think you're looking at it,
you think,
well that's an envelope.
It's like your body isn't thinking that.
Not for a bloody second.
It knows perfectly well that that's a
portal and you open it up.
It's like collapse the whole,
what would you call it,
that whole avatar related future,
just those ashes or bang,
it springs into reality and you perceive
that and that you perceive all of that
almost instantaneously and that produces
that radical transformation in emotion
so you're not reacting to the envelope
or maybe the envelope is and what you
think it is,
or maybe the envelope isn't what you see
and that's more accurate.
That's way more accurate.
The envelope is way more than what you
see.
Okay,
good.
Let's break for 15 minutes.
Okay,
and then we'll,
we'll go ahead with the next part of
this.
Well,
so that's just a transformation of the
previous diagram.
Well,
you're moving around long from what is
what should be.
We'll say
as long as things are working out well,
then you're mildly happy and if they
don't work out well then you're
downstairs.
That's another problem.
You see,
these are different sizes.
There's a reason for that and that's
because negative emotion has more
potency unit for unit than positive
emotion does.
And so what that means is that people
are more reactive.
People hate a small loss more than they
like an equivalent gain,
and so we're tilted to some degree
towards bias for negative emotion and
that is also dependent on temperament
because somebody who's very,
very low in neuroticism,
that's basically anxiety and emotional
pain susceptibility,
something like that.
So that would be the threshold for
experiencing a certain level of anxiety
or emotional pain,
but also the length of time that would
take to recover.
It's something like that.
And so,
but for the standard human being,
loss hurts more than gain rewards.
And so,
well,
it's useful to know that because it
helps you,
it helps you understand yourself and
other human beings,
even if you're trying to motivate
someone to do something,
loss avoidance is often a powerful
motivation as well as gain.
So,
alright,
prevention fundamentally.
Okay,
so now here's another way of thinking
about this and this is a more abstract
way of thinking about it.
So we talked about the idea that the
world might be divided into tools and,
and um,
and obstacles and irrelevant things,
most of which are irrelevant things.
That's a huge category.
And that's the one you don't want to
have disrupted
and also that the obstacle category
produces more emotion than the tool
category.
But here's another way of thinking about
it and this is thinking about it more
from a purely emotional perspective.
When you think about the world as tools,
it's,
it's dead practical and it sort of
grounded in the idea of motor usage and
in some sense,
but you can,
you can think in an analogical fashion
about the same system in a slightly
different matter.
You're in the situation that you're in
right now and that's not good enough.
And so that's another thing that's kind
of interesting about people.
Is there a chronically dissatisfied with
the way things are?
Well that's okay because you wouldn't be
motivated to move forward if you weren't
chronically dissatisfied with the way
that things are.
But it's kind of annoying,
you know,
because you might think,
well why aren't you just happy with what
you have?
And the answer to that is generally
because I don't know if it's going to
last.
And so that's part of it.
And the other is,
well,
if the situation shifted a bit,
maybe I'd have more options and some of
that would be,
it would last longer and be more stable,
it'd be more promising.
And so you can say,
well,
you should be satisfied with what you
have,
but it's kind of really a stupid thing
in some sense to tell human beings
because no matter what you have,
it isn't going to solve your fundamental
problem.
So the problem isn't going away and you
can't fool yourself into saying,
well,
what I have is great.
You could say,
I could have a hell of a lot less and
that would be bad,
and most people have a lot less than me
and I should be grateful for what I
have.
That's fine,
that's perfectly reasonable.
But you're stuck in this.
You're stuck with this chronic sense of
unfinished business.
And the reason for that is while you're
permanently vulnerable,
so how else would you,
how could it be otherwise?
And even if you've got your problem
solved,
then there's three or four people in
your family that by no means have got
their problem solved.
So the problem of problems never goes
away.
That's an existent.
That's a good thing to know
existentially too,
because it helps you calibrate your life
properly because you might be thinking,
well,
if I just got everything together,
you know,
I'd hit some plateau of satiation and
stability and then I would just be
there.
It's like,
no,
that's never going to happen.
It's never going to happen.
So you might as well just forget about
that and what you can sisyphus issue.
You know the guy who pushes the rock up
the road and up the hill and it rolls
back down.
I think it was Nietzsche who said,
we must presume sisyphus to be happy.
Something like that.
Well,
maybe you want to push your damn rock up
a hill,
you know it's going to roll down again.
It's like,
what are you going to do?
Just sit there by the rock.
It's okay to be active even even if the
problem you're trying to solve is not
fundamentally solvable.
That doesn't mean it isn't worth trying
to solve.
So although people can despair about it
and it's not surprising.
Okay,
so another way that I should've really
said,
instead of predicted outcome here,
this is like an old model.
This would be a model that I derived
from work that was done at least
initially in the sixties,
aren't even in the forties,
but,
and that still underlies the thinking
of,
I would say the vast majority of
psychologists,
it isn't that you're predicting outcomes
and and,
and failing.
It's not that it's that you desire
outcomes and sometimes you get an
undesirable outcome and it's really
important to get that distinction
correct because if you're thinking about
expectation is just a cold cognitive
model,
it's like a rational model.
I know the world,
I understand it's relationships.
I can predict what's going to happen
next if,
and that's what I'm trying to do is
predict it.
It's like,
no you're not,
you're not trying to predict it.
You're trying to get what you want from
it.
And there's a prediction element to
that,
which is,
well,
you know,
I'm going to pick that up.
So that's a prediction and their work
verifying my prediction,
but,
but what's missing there is I want to
pick that up and you can't throw that
out of the equation because as soon as
you throw motivation out of the
equation,
then you're stuck with the mystery of
perception,
right?
How do you organize her perceptions?
Unless you want something when you
can't,
so you don't get to get rid of the want
and just substitute cold expectation.
It's a slight of hand.
And the cognitive behaviors stew that
they almost always do that.
That's how they.
Well,
it's not like a conspiracy or anything.
It's perfectly reasonable to have a
simplified model for the way that people
act,
but you don't want to throw motivation
and emotion out of the equation because
obviously there's or embodiment there
are so important.
Okay?
So forget predicted an unpredicted
desired an undesired.
Okay?
So I come walking in here and I have
this low level desire,
which is to make my way to my podium
with the least amount of effort
necessary.
And I see that,
that chairs in the way and it's mildly
annoying.
And so there's something undesired
there.
So the desired outcome produces positive
emotion.
That's promise.
What's technically speaking?
You could also think about it as hope.
It's related to the attainment of a
goal.
It indicates the potential attainment of
a goal.
That's what hope is,
or what promise is hope is,
I can probably attain this school,
promise his promises.
If something is promising,
it indicates to you that you can
probably attain the goal or if someone
makes a promise to you,
then they're telling you that they're
going to facilitate movement towards a
goal,
and so that's the emotional level that
the dopaminergic system works on.
Again,
it's promise or hope or or technically
it's called incentive reward,
that that's the technical term,
but it's the indication that something
good is going to happen.
Well.
So when I see a clear pathway,
then I know I can make my goal pretty
efficiently and so it's going to produce
just a well.
I was going to produce enough positive
emotion to make me walk forward.
That's,
that's the right amount.
So and so it's interesting.
So you can actually use this when you're
thinking about room design or house
designed.
It's like,
so you're in a room,
you think,
well,
what am I going to use this room for?
It's like,
okay,
you sort that out.
Well then you want to make the pathways
to that use is clear and pristine as
possible,
unless you want to put in some
interesting variation just for
decoration,
but fundamentally what you're trying to
do is to set up the environment so that
it facilitates the actions you intend to
pursue there.
If you go into your room and it's all
covered with stacks of paper and they're
all messy,
you know,
and and you know the bed isn't made and
there's rubbish everywhere by your
definition of rubbish.
Then what you're doing basically is
walking into a room of snakes and it's
the same system that's responding to all
of those undone things that would
respond to snakes.
You know,
not like a Cobra that's right beside
you,
but it's the same damn circuitry.
That's the circuitry that responds to
chaos.
It's the circuitry that responds to the
dragon of chaos that makes you
uncomfortable.
In a room like that,
it's,
it's not explored territory.
It's not a place where you can easily
see the proper relationship between the
tools and the obstacles.
It's not a place that you can make
things irrelevant,
not at all.
In fact,
it's a place full of obstacles.
How are you going to be comfortable in a
room like that?
It's full of things that get in the way
of your goals.
You're going to be nervous in there all
the time,
so it's like it's full of envelopes that
you haven't opened and most of them have
bad news in.
You're not going to be comfortable in a
room like that.
You think,
why can't you just ignore those
envelopes?
It's like,
well,
it's a stupid way of looking at it,
so promise produces hope slash pleasure,
curiosity.
All the incentive reward related
emotions sort of fit in that box and
then undesired outcomes produce threat.
There are threats and they produce
anxiety,
but that's not even exactly right.
That's in an elementary discussion of
the role of competitor systems in the
brain,
which we'll talk about in more detail.
The general notion is is that the
violation of an expectation produces
anxiety and that that's a pretty good
model and you got some support from the
psychophysiological pharmacological
literature because if you give animals
antianxiety agents like benzodiazepines
or alcohol or barbiturates,
they do respond less to the violation of
quote expectancy.
It does dampen the response,
but but it's an oversimplified model and
to get understanding of human behavior,
correct,
you have to expand it a bit.
It isn't precisely that
unpredicted outcome is a threat and it
produces anxiety.
It's that unpredicted outcome makes the
irrelevant relevant and it produces an
undifferentiated emotional and
motivational state.
It's a better way of thinking about it
because it isn't just that you don't
just get anxious.
For example,
if something goes wrong,
you get anxious,
you get angry,
you get curious,
you get frustrated,
you get depressed,
like it's a whole bursting forward of
emotions and motivational states and
that's because when something doesn't
work the way it's supposed to,
even when you just encounter an
obstacle,
it means that you're the way that you're
construing the landscape is wrong in
some manner and you don't exactly know
what you're going to have to do in order
to fix that unless it's a very trivial,
trivial violation and it's one that you
know immediately how to readdress.
Like if I'm again,
so I come around the corner and I look
at that chair and I'm annoyed because
it's in the way you might think,
well how annoyed should I get?
And the answer should be something like
your annoyance should be in proportion
to the amount of time and energy it will
take to move that chair.
Right?
Because that's kind of like a proper
perception.
So it's like I should be that annoyed.
I should be annoyed enough so that I've
indexed doing that because that does
actually take some and energy.
And that actually has a cost and the
fact that I have to pay that cost
shouldn't be signified by something
because otherwise I wouldn't be
sensitive to costs.
And so the annoyance,
if it's in proportion to the effort,
is exactly.
Index property.
Now often,
unfortunately you don't know how to
index.
So you have an old car,
you're driving to work,
someone bumps you from behind,
and then your car doesn't work.
It's like,
well,
how annoyed should you get?
You don't know.
That's a problem.
And so then all of a sudden a bunch of
things that were irrelevant,
which is the whole damn car poof,
become relevant.
Plus you have to deal with this person
that just ran into you and what are they
like?
Well,
they're stupid enough to run into you so
you don't know what else might be wrong
with them and maybe they're going to be
a bunch of trouble and you have to get
their insurance information and now
you're on the side of the road and you
don't know if you're going to go to
work.
And so that's when your emotions can
unravel because they're trying to
compute the effort and time you're going
to have to take in order to rectify this
and this span,
this,
the,
the what you'd call it,
the domain that is opening up as a
consequence of the problem isn't easy to
map and so you get stressed and you go
home and say,
I had a stressful day,
and the person says,
what happened?
While someone hit me on the highway?
And they go,
oh,
that's terrible.
They figured that out.
It's like,
well,
I was in this little map.
It was only this long.
I was just going from here to here and
all of a sudden booth.
I didn't know where I was or how many
places I was going to have to wander
around in before I could get that map
working again.
But the car is an invisible predicate of
multiple potential future maps as well,
right?
It's an axiom.
You make the map presuming that you have
the car and the car isn't a metal thing
with wheels.
The car is a conveyance for moving you
from point a to point b,
and the fact that you have all these
maps of moving from point a to b that
are predicated on that conveyance means
that when it turns into a car instead of
a conveyance,
poof,
all those maps become extremely
complicated as well.
And so your body goes,
well,
I'm.
My landscape is way more complex than I
thought.
Up goes the heart rate up,
close the cortisol,
all of that,
right,
and you're more paralyzed and you can
like if you're a neurotic person,
let's say something like that can just
paralyze you.
You're done.
You have to phone someone for emergency
help,
which means you're in a map that you
cannot put your map back together.
You have to call on outside,
help in order to do it.
So and you might not even know how to do
that.
Okay,
so that's another way.
Now here's another way of thinking about
it.
You want to stay inside this little map
because it's working.
You want to get from point a to point a
to point b,
and this is good.
This indicates that you are moving
forward,
that's the first thing it indicates and
the second thing it indicates,
which is even more important,
and you'll never hear this from
behavioral psychologists,
is that your map is correct,
so every time you move a little bit and
something that you want happens,
it says,
oh,
the game I'm playing is the right gate,
and so not only does the reward indicate
progress,
it indicates that the frame within which
progress is being calculated is the
right frame and that's good because it's
the frame that makes things irrelevant
and you want them to stay irrelevant.
So if you don't move forward and you
start to question the frame that's way
worse than merely not moving forward.
You get a bad exam grade,
what do you think?
What the hell am I doing in university
anyways?
It's like probably that's not the first
place you should go with that piece of
information and you think,
well,
why?
Why is that worse?
Well,
as far as I can tell,
your map of view as a university student
is a comprehensive representation.
It tells you what you should do
everyday.
It kind of tells you where you're going
into the future and if something emerges
as an the.
Normally you get worse grade than you
expected and you blow that whole map.
It's like,
okay,
what have you been doing for the last
four years?
What kind of high school student were
you?
How clueless are you about how you're
arranging your future?
What's your identity going to be?
If you're not going to be a student,
where are you going to end up in five
years?
So like,
so it's like that little grade,
that bad grade is like a portal through
which snakes can crawl and that's
exactly how you respond to it.
Especially if you open the door too
much.
Well maybe this means that I shouldn't
be in university.
Well,
one of the rules is don't you want to.
You want to constrain the anomalous
event to the minimal necessary domain.
It's really,
really important.
You want to do that when you're arguing
with your partner,
which will do all the time.
We have an argument,
well,
I should never have married you.
It's like,
no,
that's not the first response.
That's a bad response,
or here's a really good one.
You've always done that sort of thing
and you always will.
It's like,
oh good,
great.
It's like the only answer to that is to
hit someone because like you're done
right?
Your your life,
that you've always been like that.
There isn't a chance that you can be
repaired and none of it is acceptable.
It's like the person's gonna fight with
you right away because what else are
they going to do?
So what you want to do is you want to
minimize.
It isn't rationalization.
You want to say,
okay,
this person did something that disrupted
our joint map.
Okay,
what's the smallest possible thing they
could do to put it back together?
And you have to know,
well,
we need to make a plan so you don't do
it again.
Or we need to have a discussion so that
you know that it wasn't a good thing to
do,
but I'm not going to go after your whole
character.
I'm going to say when I come home and
you're watching TV,
just come to the door and say hello,
not,
don't you love me?
Or something like that.
It's like,
no,
you just have to walk to the door and
like give me a hug or something,
and then that's good enough,
and so then the other person might be
able to tolerate that much corrective
information.
Maybe if you're kind of Nice about it
and you also understand that they're
probably going to have something equally
horrible to say about you in the next 15
minutes because you're going to do
something stupid so so you don't wanna
you don't wanna open the door so that
every possible snake comes crawling
through because that's a pathway to
depression and you actually see that
happening in depressed people is that
every small event produces a cascade
through their entire value system and
they ended up saying,
well,
that's just another reason that I should
jump off a bridge,
and they really see it that way.
It's really awful because they've got no
defenses.
It's like,
well,
I didn't do so well in this course.
It's like I'm going to get a bad mark in
the or in the exam.
I'm going to get bad mark in the course
that's going to screw up my ability to
finish my degree.
I'm never going to get into the field of
my choice.
It's just another piece of indication
that I'm useless and that life isn't
worthwhile.
Bang,
I'm going to jump off a bridge and if
you're really depressed,
it's like each of those things hits you
with the certainty of truth.
It's really not good and so you want to
be careful.
You want to be careful about walking
down that pathway when you make a
mistake,
you think,
okay,
what's the narrowest framework of
interpretation within which I can.
I can understand this.
That will require minimal behavioral
change to decrease the probability that
it will happen.
Again,
it's mental hygiene fundamentally.
Yes.
Yeah.
We'll get to that.
That is the next question.
It's because they don't exist in
isolation,
so and that's another thing.
Frequently when when you,
when you hear behavioral accounts of
cognitive processes,
they generally only focus on it as if
it's an isolated thing.
It's not.
It is.
It's scalable.
A bunch of ways it scalable temporarily
because what you do now is associated
with what you'll do tomorrow and that
with what you'll do next week and so
forth,
so it has to be scalable temporarily and
it's also scalable socially,
right,
so it has an effect on you that has an
effect on your family that has an effect
on the community and so forth and so you
don't want to take.
It's very difficult to think through the
effect of your actions and all those
scaling link level simultaneously,
but,
but you have mechanisms that allow you
to do that and we'll see.
I think that the sense of let's assume
that you're not lying to yourself
constantly so your head isn't full of
chaos and garbage and you have
reasonable relationships with people in
the world.
I think that this is leaping way ahead.
I think that your sense of meaningful
engagement with what you're doing is the
psychophysiological marker,
that you're acting in a way that takes
all of the stacked representations into
account simultaneously because you're.
You're,
you're,
you're like,
you're trying to figure out where you
are and you might think,
well,
that means where I am in this room,
but look,
this room is not a simple thing,
right?
It's nested.
It's,
it's a subset of the university that's a
subset of society.
It's a subset of your life.
The room is a complicated thing and you
need to figure out where you should be
in the room and you can't do that shit
surely with perception because all you
see is me and some of the wall,
right?
It's got this little narrow,
this little narrow portal,
and so you can't really rely on your
perceptions to Orient you,
but you do Orient Yourself and I think
what you do is you.
It's engagement.
It's like,
does this seem meaningful and deep and
engaging?
Yes.
Then it's an indication that it's
serving multiple masters simultaneously,
so both maybe both socially and also
temporarily,
and so I think the sense of meaning is
actually an instinct that orients people
in time and space.
It's not an EPA phenomena.
It's the most fundamental form of
perception and that's the only
optimistic thought that I've ever been
able to derive from psychology is that
that actually could be true.
It could be that the sense of meaning is
an orienting reflex and that would be
wonderful if it was true because it
would make it real,
you know,
and it's one of the,
the one of the devastating elements of
nihilism is something like,
well,
who the hell cares what you're doing,
what differences are going to make in a
million years?
It's like your sense of meaning is just
an illusion.
You know,
you're,
you're limited creature in a limited
place and nothing you do really matters.
It's like that's a powerful argument,
especially if you're an objective
materialist in a reductionist.
It's a killer argument,
but it looks to me like it's wrong.
It's actually wrong because meaning
looks to me like it's an actual
phenomenon.
It does say that you're positioned
properly between chaos and order,
something like that.
It's a real so.
Well.
So we'll see.
We're gonna develop that argument
because if,
if it's real,
you want to know that because it gives
you something to stand on,
you know,
maybe it's as real as pain,
but it's not pain.
It's something positive and you need
something positive that you can rely on.
All right,
so we're concentrating now on the
unpredicted outcome or the undesired
outcome because we said,
well,
that's like a portal.
It's a portal through which doubt can
pour and it's the thing that makes the
irrelevant relevant to get.
And so that's why I use this little
diagram.
It's like,
oh,
that's a,
that's a fear face roughly speaking,
and I put all those stripes on it to
indicate that it's not just fear,
it's preparation for all sorts of
different,
for all sorts of different perceptions
and all sorts of different motivational
states.
So imagine what happens when something
knocks you back on your heels.
It's like not only does your body
prepare,
but simultaneously with all of that
preparation,
all sorts of fantasies are generated
like,
and what they are is all sorts of
alternative worlds.
Well why did this happen?
You go back into your past and you say,
well,
here's one route.
Well,
here's another.
Here's another,
Here's another route,
like I don't know what I did wrong.
I don't know what anybody did wrong,
but there's something back there that
someone did wrong and he can take people
years to sort that out,
and so those fantasies are all
generated.
Then the same thing happens with the
future.
It's like,
well,
what does this mean?
Well,
it could mean this.
It could mean that it could be not
getting divorced.
It could mean I'm losing my house.
It could mean I'll never talk to my kids
again.
It could mean that my career is going to
collapse,
right?
Or maybe I'll get,
be able to get out of this stupid job
that I've always hated.
Something better will happen all at the
same time.
So that's,
that's the response to a normally.
And the reason you respond that way is
because you're no longer where you
thought you were.
Okay?
So there's a simple way of looking at
it.
So what,
what does an unpredicted or anomalous
event mean?
And I think this is,
this is maybe the most important thing,
the most important theme of the entire
class might be what does an unpredicted
or undesired outcome mean?
The only thing that would be equally
important is what should you do about
it?
But we'll start with what it means.
And the answer is,
well,
you don't know what it means.
It could mean anything.
And that's a strange category,
right?
The category of the normalist events
contains indefinite possibility.
So what the hell do you do about that?
While you prepare to do a variety of
things,
you can simplify it and say,
well,
it's half threat because something bad
might happen and it's half promise
because something good might happen.
Okay?
So that's a good way of thinking about
it.
It's a portal.
All of a sudden,
instead of the thing being irrelevant,
the thing is ambivalent.
It contains some slice of all possible
meanings,
positive and negative.
Okay?
So you're trying to sort that out.
That's partly why it's so stressful to.
And anger is a good response to that
because anger is partly.
It's partly an advanced emotion because
it's got a positive emotion element,
which is why anger can be righteous,
you know,
but it's got a negative element to it's
negative emotion and positive emotion at
the same thing,
same time.
So it's like the canonical stress,
emotion.
So,
but it's very hard on people.
Anger.
It's very cycle physiologically
demanding.
So I started with that model and then I
developed it into this model which I
liked better.
So you're moving from,
you haven't seen this because it's not
in the book.
Moving from point a to point B and
you're using your actions that you're
known actions to get there.
Okay.
And what happens you,
you run into an anomaly and it's like a
hole.
It's a hole through the map.
It's like a whole is burned in it or
something like that.
And the maps no longer relevant.
And so what happens while you're
positive emotion systems are activated
or disinhibited.
That's a better way of thinking about
it.
And your negative emotion systems are
disinhibited.
And what might those be?
Well,
in positive emotion you have hope and
interest in exhilaration and curiosity
and confidence.
And in the negative emotional space,
you have anxiety and fear and hurt and
anger and guilt and shame and
disappointment in disgust,
like there's quite a stacking of
emotions and you don't know which of
those is going to be useful and relevant
and so it all emerges at the same time.
Now,
one,
the questions that was being bagged,
let's say by this discussion,
was the idea of the relationship between
these frames of reference to one
another.
I'm going to describe that relationship
because one of the things that I want to
describe to you is how you determine how
upset you should be when something
normal.
This happens because it's really hard to
figure out.
Right?
So because,
well you see this often,
especially if you're unsophisticated in
dispute settlement with an intimate
partner,
every little bump and the relationship
is the potential disillusion of the
entire relationship.
That's actually why people get married,
you know,
just so you know,
because this is built into marital vows,
I'm not leaving ever no matter what.
It's like,
okay,
well that definitely puts a boundary
around our arguments,
right?
Because I can't say every time you
manifest one of your flaws,
which you're likely to do just as often
as me.
Well enough of this,
it's like,
that's horrible,
man.
If your whole life is while every time
you get out of line,
I'm out of here.
It's like,
how the hell are you?
First of all,
you're not going to admit to ever doing
anything wrong.
Second,
you're going to be on your.
You're like,
ah,
like a scared cat.
The entire relationship because well,
who knows?
It could just come to an end at any
moment.
It's like,
you know,
people say,
well,
if you're.
If the possibility of divorce is open,
it makes you free.
It's like,
yeah,
that's what you want.
You want to be free.
A really,
really,
so you can't predict anything.
That's what you're after.
It's a vow and it says,
look,
I know that your trouble me too,
so we won't leave.
No matter what happens.
Well,
that's a hell of a vowel,
but that's why it's about right.
That's why you take it in front of a
bunch of people.
That's why it's supposed to be a sacred
act.
It's like,
what's the alternative?
What's the alternative?
Everything is mutable and changeable at
any moment.
Well,
go ahead.
You liver,
your liver,
your life like that and see what you're
like when you're 50 Jesus.
It's dismal.
Two or three divorces.
Your family's fragmented.
You've got no continuity of narrative.
It's not.
It's not good for the kids,
not by any stretch of the imagination
and so it's a form of voluntary
enslavement I suppose,
but it's also equivalent to the adoption
of a responsibility and there's more to
it than that.
If you can't run away,
then you can solve your problems because
it might be,
okay,
well I'm stuck with you,
so how about we fix things
because the alternative is we're going
to be in a boxing match for the next 40
years.
That's the alternative.
So and you think you're going to fix
problems without something like that
hanging over your head.
There isn't a chance.
You'll just avoid them because that's
what people do.
It's really hard to.
To solve problems,
especially in relationship.
We're having a fight and I find out that
it's because you're.
You were abused by your uncle when you
were five or some God damn thing.
You know,
it's like it.
It's very to third sort of thing
happens.
You,
there's the partner,
your partner's manifesting some weird
anomalous behavior.
You just can't make heads or tails of
it.
That doesn't seem related to what you're
doing at all.
They don't want to talk about it.
And so as soon as you bring it up,
they get mad.
Then you bring it up again.
They even get mad or and they tell you
that you're not going to talk about that
or they're going to leave and so maybe
you really,
really persistent because you're kind of
a son of a bitch and then they break
down and cry,
you know,
and then they have this horrible memory
that comes flooding forward that's
completely.
You don't know what to do with it and
then you have to sort it out.
It's like,
you think you're going to do that unless
there's a good reason.
You have to know we better start this
out or we're going to be carrying it
around for the next 40 years.
That may be is enough motivation,
so you'll actually try hard to solve a
problem.
It's a lot easier to say,
well sorry,
we're not going there,
but then good.
And you'll have it every day.
Every day,
every God damn day for the rest of your
life.
Anyways,
back to this.
Alright,
so what's the relationship between your
frames of reference?
Well,
we can.
We can.
Well we,
let's do it this way.
Let's see if I can think of a good.
Have a good example.
Why did you get up this morning?
Okay.
Why?
Why did you want to come to class this
class?
Okay,
so why do you want to come?
This is a serious question.
Why did you want to come to class?
To get the knowledge that it's going to
be.
That is something I'm going to be tested
on.
Okay.
Is there,
is there any reason other than the
testing that you came to class?
It's okay.
You can start.
This is not a trap.
You can say whatever you want.
I'm just sitting there just they're just
straight questions.
Okay.
So let's say no for the time being or
not for reasons that you can immediately
bring to mind.
Okay.
Why does the test matter?
For the degree?
Okay.
Why does,
why do you care about the degree?
To get a job.
Okay.
Whose decision was it that you took?
The degree that you're taking your.
Okay.
Did your parents have any influence on
that?
No.
No?
Okay.
What job are you after?
Psychology,
psychology.
Clinical clinical psychologist.
Why do you want to do that again?
You don't.
I'm gonna question you.
Until you run out of answers,
you will run out of answers.
So if this is the time,
that's fine.
Why do you want to.
Do you want to do clinical psychology to
help people?
To help people.
Okay.
Why is that more important to you than
making money?
Because it helps me in interact.
How it sort of makes me happy to see
other people get over
their pro.
Okay.
All right,
good,
good.
Well that's pretty good.
You had lots of answers so sometimes you
can run people out of answers with about
three questions.
So.
Alright.
So small action perception,
nested in larger action perception,
nested in larger action perception all
the way out to well,
until you run out of answers
fundamentally,
right?
So,
and that's where it's at the edge where
you run out of answers,
that's where metaphysics takes over
because there's not an irrational domain
anymore.
You're in a metaphysical domain at that
point and so you have implicit
assumptions that you don't even know
about that are working on,
on the fringes.
And we'll talk about that a little bit.
Okay?
So,
so then we can take a category like,
hmm,
we'll do a micro analysis the same way.
So you're at home and you're tickling
the baby.
All right?
So we'll note first.
That's not an abstraction,
right?
There's an actual baby and you're moving
your fingers.
And so that's not just an abstract
conceptualization.
It's also where your consciousness ends.
You're tickling the baby,
but you don't know how you're doing it.
You don't know the musculature,
you don't know how to manipulate the
little organs and everything.
You can just do it.
So Bang,
you're out of the perceptual domain at
that point.
It grounds out in voluntary action.
Alright,
so you're tickling the baby.
What are you doing when you're tickling
the baby while you're making the baby
laugh?
Okay,
that's one way you're playing with the
baby.
Okay,
so fine.
That's a subset of the activity.
Play with baby and you can play peekaboo
with the baby.
You can tickle the baby,
you can clean the baby and all of that
can be part of playing and you might
say,
well,
what are you doing when you're playing
with a baby?
And you'd say,
well,
I'm taking care of my family and fine,
and then you think,
well what?
What are you doing when you're taking
care of your family?
And you might say,
well,
I'm being a good parent,
and then you might say,
well what am I doing when I'm being a
good parent?
You might say,
well,
I'm being a good person.
And then you could say,
well why should you be a good person?
But we won't go any farther than that.
It's of because you can see that that's
sort of the.
In some sense,
that's an ultimate level of abstraction.
Okay,
so you could.
What do you do if someone comes up to
you and you're tickling the baby and you
say,
well,
I'm being a good person.
They ask,
what are you doing?
I'm being a good person.
It's like it's a bit disjointed.
It doesn't what the person would expect
as an answer.
They expect something more local,
but it's still true.
And so what's interesting is that when
you're doing something that's
what.
Well,
I would say worthwhile.
That's probably the right way of
thinking about it.
You're doing a whole bunch of things
simultaneously and you're not really
aware of all those things,
but you are in some sense,
you know,
because if the person,
someone might come along and say,
well what kind of idiot tickles a baby
like that?
It's like,
well,
what have they said?
Well they've kind of nailed you here
down on the micro tickle level,
but there are sort of also
taking a pretty good crack at this high
level system as well now.
And that's a problem.
So let's say,
well good parent is a subset of being a
good person,
but there's all sorts of other baby.
You have to be a good partner.
Maybe you have to be a good daughter.
Maybe you have to be a good nice,
you know your,
your,
your ability to function as a good
person is composed of a very large
number of hierarchically nested
subsystems.
And so when the person goes,
only an idiot would tickle the baby like
that.
And they go after that.
You might think,
well,
how upset you should,
should you get an answer is well,
how valid do you think their complaint
is?
So let's say maybe it only an idiot
wouldn't take all the baby like that and
you happened to be that idiot and so,
well maybe you're not a good person.
And so what does that mean?
It means that the map that consists of
all these nested subsistence has now
become unreliable.
And so how upset are you going to get
about that?
Well,
you know,
maybe you had a bad day at work and
you're kind of hypoglycemic and you had
too much to drink the night before.
And so someone says,
you know,
that's not how you take a baby.
You idiot and you cry.
Well,
why?
it's a pretty high level blow and so
it's the sort of thing you want to do if
you want to do,
if you want to hurt someone,
it's not a good way to teach someone
because you teach them down at the
smallest possible level.
The micro,
no,
you don't take all the baby like that.
You tickle a baby like this and you're
doing a good job on everything else,
but if you're going to tickle the baby,
this is how you go about it and the
person thinks,
well,
you know,
I'm doing a fairly good job,
but it's got this little thing I have to
work on and maybe I can manage it,
and so that works and that works and you
can have some sympathy for the person at
the same time because you might say,
well,
I used to take a baby.
He's like an idiot too,
but you know it's,
it's fixable and most of use.
Okay?
And that's a nice thing to do when
you're arguing with someone.
You say,
look,
here's a bunch of things you're doing
right that are related to this that are
important.
Here's this small thing that maybe you
could alter slightly and it would make
me happy and maybe I'll return the favor
at some point and they think,
oh well maybe,
maybe I'll do that maybe,
and then they practice doing it and you
can give them a pat on the head and then
you're both happy about that.
That really works with people.
It really works.
So okay,
so what you see is that these high level
abstractions,
let's call them ethical abstractions,
are related to actions.
They're related and so you can see that
relationship from the good person to
doing something like tickle the baby
properly and then you can.
You can conceptualize it this way,
that you have this massive overarching
map which is something like the story of
your life,
including its extension,
the future,
and then it consists of these
subordinate maps which can be broken
down all the way down to the level of
actions and so then that explains to you
to some degree how you can do the
impossible job of calibrating your
emotional response.
Because roughly speaking,
emotional response should be
proportionate to the level that's being
assaulted by the anomaly,
right?
If it's way up here,
you wrote your amcap because you want to
go to medical school,
right?
And so now the envelope comes and you're
shaking away and the open ended,
it's like you got 25th percentile,
just like a quarter of the people who
take the test.
Well,
what?
What does that mean?
Well,
this is all blown to hell,
that's for sure.
And so God only knows how many of these
things are going to go to.
Maybe your study habits really need to
be.
You know,
you have to reconstitute yourself all
the way down to the level of your
habits.
It's,
it can be devastating news.
Now,
one of the ways to protect yourself
against something like that,
it's like don't have one plan,
right?
If you're going to stake yourself on
something,
you should throw a couple of alternative
scaffolds up beside you so that you have
somewhere to go.
You want to be a doctor?
Okay,
well you could be a nurse.
It's like it's not a doctor,
but it needs cutting your throat.
You're still doing 80 percent of what
you wanted to do,
so you want to and you want to think
about this during your whole life,
man,
if you're going to take a high risk,
you want to scaffold yourself in other
areas so that if it fails,
you don't bother them,
doesn't drop out and you die and it's
also very much worth thinking about with
regards to setting up your life in
general.
It's like if you concentrate solely on
your career,
you can get along way in your career and
I would say that that's a strategy that
a minority of men preferentially do that
that's all they do.
They worked like 70,
80 hours a week.
They'd go flat out on their career.
They're staking everything on the small
probability of exceptional status in a
narrow domain,
but it's.
It's hard on them.
They don't have a life.
It's very difficult for them to have a
family.
They don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very one
dimension.
Now,
it may be that that unit dimensionality
is the price you have to pay to be
exceptional at one thing,
right?
Because if you're going to be something
like a genius level mathematician and
you want to do that for,
or scientists say,
it's like you're in your lab,
you're in your lab all the time.
You're working 70 hours a week or 80
hours a week,
you're smart,
you're dedicated,
you're unidimensional,
and that's how you get to beat all the
other people who are doing that.
It's the only way,
but the problem is you don't get a life.
Now,
if you love being a scientist and you
have that kind of focus of mind,
well first of all,
you're a rare person and second you're
going to pay for it,
but fine.
More power to you.
But,
but it's,
uh,
it's a risky business to do that.
You sacrifice a lot for it,
you know,
and I would say most often if you're
speaking about having a healthy life,
that isn't what you do.
You spread yourself out more.
So you know,
you have a family,
you have some things that you do outside
of work that are meaningful to you and
useful you,
you have a network of friends,
um,
that,
those three things,
a loaner for things,
a loner,
plenty to keep you well oriented.
And then if one of those things
collapses,
you know,
everything doesn't go now.
The price you pay for that is,
the more you strive to optimize that
balance,
the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them.
But you might have a very,
you know,
if you can consider your life as a
whole,
that might be a winning strategy.
One of the things Carl Young said,
I really liked this.
He thought that men went after
perfection and when women went after
wholeness,
so there are different.
They're different value there,
there are different,
there's something different at the top
of the value hierarchy.
So perfection would be steak it all on
one thing and look for radical success.
Not all,
not that all men do that because they
don't.
But what we're talking about extremes,
at least with regards to the men that do
that,
the wholeness ideas more like,
well,
I want,
I want.
It's like I want one thing in my life to
be 150 percent or I want five things in
my life to be 80 percent.
Well there,
there's a lot more richness in a life
where you have five things operating at
80 percent,
but you're not operating in any at any
of them at 150 percent.
So,
and I really believe this because I've
watched men and women go through their
careers now for a long period of time
and one of the things that,
there's lots of things that produced
this,
but one of the things that I've noticed
is that mostly women in their thirties
bear bail out of unit dimensional
careers.
They won't do them.
They won't.
They won't put in the 80 hours a week
that they would have to put in in order
to dominate that particular area.
And it isn't.
The reason that they won't do it is
because they decide it's not worth it.
And no wonder because why would that be
worth it?
You have to ask yourself that.
It's like,
well,
you want to be an outstanding
scientists.
Like,
okay,
really,
really that's what you want because that
means that's what you do
[inaudible],
you're competing with other people,
you know,
they're smart,
they're hardworking,
and if you want to be at the top,
you have to be smarter and work harder
than any of them.
And working hard means working long
hours.
I mean it also means working diligently,
but in the final analysis,
it's also an additive issue.
If I'm smart and hardworking and I can
crank out for 70 hours a week and you do
it for 30,
it's like in two years,
I'm so far ahead of you.
You will never ever catch up.
So anyways.
And I think partly maybe part of the
reason too that women are oriented that
way more than men.
I think there's two reasons.
One is socioeconomic status does not
make women more attractive on the mating
market,
but it does make men more attractive.
And the second is women's timeframe is
compressed,
right?
Because guys can always say,
well,
I'll have kids later and they can say
that until they're like 80.
Whereas women,
it's like,
no way man.
You gotta get it.
You gotta get it together by the time
you're,
let's say 40,
but really probably by 35,
but definitely by 40 because it ain't
happening.
And that's bloody dreadful.
Like the most unhappy people you ever
see.
No,
no.
One of the common roots to extreme
unhappiness is to want children and not
have the.
I wouldn't recommend that.
You know,
you see couples who were in their
thirties,
one couple in three over the age of 30
has fertility problems that's defined as
an inability to conceive after one year
of trying one in three.
So it's worth thinking about because
people are very,
very unhappy if they want to have kids
and then they can't,
man,
you're in the medical mill for 10 years,
if that's,
if that's what happens to you.
So.
Okay.
So anyways,
back to this.
I think what I'll do,
what time it is,
it is it because I'd have to open up
whole new can of worms,
so to speak,
to do the next part.
So I think actually what I'm going to do
is just recap what we did and then stop
or maybe we can have some questions or
maybe we can call it an early day.
Okay,
so what,
what is the fundamental issue here?
What did we discuss today?
All right,
so you're in a frame and we've laid out
its characteristics.
It has a goal in it,
it has a current position,
it has rules for operating within it.
It governs your perceptions,
which is really critical thing to
understand and we're all governing your
perceptions.
It's,
it tells you what's useful to you and
what gets in your way,
but most importantly,
it tells you what.
You don't have to pay attention to it.
So as long as your damn frame is
functional,
you can ignore most of the world and
that means your stress level is way
lower than it would normally be.
Okay?
So perception,
motivation,
all of that's integrated into those
frames.
And then the emotional element comes out
in that with you when you're within a
frame,
things that move you forward and
validate the framer positive and things
that get in your way and invalidate the
frame are negative,
and then the next issue is,
well,
if your frame is invalidated,
exactly what does that mean?
And you can't answer that without
thinking about the hierarchy of frames
because if you're lucky,
it just means your frame needs a minor
alteration that would be equivalent to
piaget in assimilation in some sense.
Right?
You can stay in the frame.
You just make a small adjustment.
I think the Piaget Eddie and distinction
between assimilation and accommodation
is technically inaccurate because it's a
continuum,
right?
I mean if I.
If I want to grab your pen,
I have a little frame that will enable
me to do that.
You say,
well,
I'm staying within the frame to move
that out of the way,
but actually I'm not.
What I'm doing is doing a very.
I'm doing a small micro revolution in
the frame.
Moving that to pick that up.
And so it's.
I think accommodation.
There's no hard distinction between
assimilation and accommodation,
it's a continuum.
So you'd say,
well,
if the top end of your map gets blown
out,
that requires accommodation and if it's
just a little micro change at the
bottom,
that's assimilation,
but there's no,
there's no real difference between
except for scale and there's kind of a
continual scale,
not an absolute dichotomy.
So.
Okay.
So anyways,
back to the back to the emotion.
Something happens and it isn't what you
wanted.
What does that mean?
Well,
it could mean anything.
What you do is you start trying to micro
adjust the frame at the highest level of
resolution,
but then you might find that you can't
do that.
So you have to jump up to the next one.
You have to jump up to the next one,
you have to jump up to the next one.
And each time you do that,
the psychophysiological cost increases.
So,
okay,
so,
so we talked about the cost end of the
spectrum and then we also talked about
the engagement end of the spectrum.
And so the idea would be,
well,
if you're,
if you're very much engaged,
say in,
let's go do that again.
If you find it very engaging to play
with your baby,
then you might be doing it in a way
that's in indicating that you're taking
good care of your family,
that you're being a good parent and that
you're being a good person all
simultaneously,
where there's rich meaning in that,
and you're the systems that orient you
with regards to meaning or saying,
look,
you're doing this microaction in a way
that benefits the maintenance and maybe
even the expansion of all the frames
that exist above it.
And that's,
that's,
that's exactly what you want.
You want to be doing that all the time
if you can't.
And so that implies that you want to
delineate out a pretty well developed
value system so that you're not acting
at odds with yourself.
And you also want to have that
integrated within the broader society so
that society isn't existing towards you
as a continual obstacle then making your
life miserable.
So.
Okay,
good questions.
Any of that not make sense?
Or do you have any objections to it?
It's funny.
It's funny,
I mentioned the word matter,
you know,
because things are made out of matter or
maybe they're made out of what matters.
But the word object is the same thing.
You could say that the world is made out
of objects or you can say that the world
has made out of what objects and both of
those,
both of those,
weirdly enough,
furry,
they're equally true in some sense.
Question,
were you?
Yes.
Queen b?
No.
It's the serotonin system in all
likelihood.
So serotonin seems.
So the question was positive emotions
mediated by dopamine.
When you're advancing towards something,
say,
or when you have a cue that something
good is about to happen.
What is the system that mediates emotion
at the satiation level
be negative?
Yup.
Okay.
Well,
let's start with the satiation issue
that seems most deregulated by
Serotonin.
The opiate issue is there are other
forms of specific reward that don't seem
to be merely motivated or merely
underpinned by dopamine.
And the opiate system would be one of
those.
There's an oxytocin system as well,
so there are other biochemical systems
that are involved in more specific forms
of reward,
but the thing that's common among
instances that make it appear that
you're moving forward is the
dopaminergic element,
roughly speaking,
and then
one of the things that happens if you're
hiring serotonin because you're more
dominant,
is that you're more satiated all the
time.
That's why people who are low in the
dominance hierarchy with decreased
levels of Serotonin are more impulsive
and also more emotionally dysregulated.
They're more impulsive because,
hey,
you take your positive thing when you
can get it,
and so they're.
They're more dissatisfied.
They're more looking for anything that
will produce a positive
outcome,
and then
they're also more likely to experience
dyfs negative emotion.
Partly because their serotonin systems
are lower,
indicating their tenuous status in the
dominance hierarchy.
Meaning that everything they do that's
uncertain is far more dangerous.
So this is also why it's very difficult
often when you're trying to treat
someone who's depressed because you
could say there's not much difference
between being depressed and existing in
the biochemical state.
That being at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy would produce,
in fact they're the same thing.
Well then the question is,
are you depressed or are you just at the
bottom of a dominance hierarchy?
Because those are not like the
symptomatology is very,
very similar,
but the cause and the cure are not the
same.
You know,
because you might be at the bottom of a
dominant Turkey because you just.
Everything about your life is ruined.
So.
And of course your suffering.
Are you depressed,
sir?
No,
not exactly.
You just have nowhere to go.
So
other questions?
Yes.
Why pursue motivations that don't
produce this residence?
Okay,
so the question is why don't,
why do people pursue rewards that don't
produce this resonance?
They don't have a value hierarchy.
So pleasure island.
It's a good example.
Those kids that were brought there were
lost.
So they didn't,
they didn't have anywhere to go.
They didn't have an identity.
So they default to local pleasure
and that's better than none.
Although the problem with local
pleasure,
while as the narrative made clear is
that you better look out if you're
impulsive because it's going to kick
back on you heart,
and the reason is you're only
considering the immediate timeframe and
the problem is,
is that things propagate across all the
timeframes and so just because something
works really well,
this second,
cocaine for example,
doesn't mean that it's a tenable
solution to the class of all problems.
So usually often people pursue local
pleasure because that's the best they
could imagine.
It's the best they've been taught.
They don't see another alternative.
So it could be ignorance,
it can be they don't want to adopt the
responsibility because part of the
problem with working at every level of
the hierarchy simultaneously is that
it's,
well,
it's like dancing to a very complex
waltz.
Let's say.
You have to be paying attention to a
very large number of things
simultaneously and doing things right.
It requires responsibility and so you
know that's
it's a pain.
It's a weight.
Part of the reason people drink alcohol
is to get rid of their responsibility.
I mean,
that's what you hear people drink
because they have problems.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
some people drink because they're
anxious and alcoholics drink because
they're in withdrawal,
but young people drink because they're
sick and tired of being responsible
because it's annoying.
It's like,
so I'll drink enough.
I won't care about the medium to
longterm consequences because alcohol,
that's exactly what alcohol does.
It doesn't make you inderal of the
medium to longterm consequences,
but it makes you not care about them and
partly it's because it dampens anxiety,
so it dampens anxiety,
leaves your positive emotion circuits
intact,
so then you can go out there and do
stupid,
fun things and that's like,
that's a party really.
Let's go do stupid fun things.
That's a party,
but the medium to longterm consequences
are.
It's risky.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't do it,
but it's risky.
So yeah,
they don't know better.
That's the answer I would say.
So yes.
You were talking about responsibility.
It seems like that balance of burst into
a certain frame and
now that's where conservatives and
liberals don't get along because
conservatives do bind themselves to a
particular frame.
They're conscientious and low in
openness and the liberals say doesn't
that just bind you to a particular
frame?
And it's like,
yeah it does and that's a problem.
So yes,
but in terms of being aware of the
multiple levels it takes within a frame
takes certain amount of tolerance of the
unbearable president for that to reach
the edge of that frame to force a person
to see a different frame because that's
something that sentence.
Yes.
And that's actually where I stopped
today because that's,
that's exactly right.
So you're,
you're good because both the questions
you asked indicated that you're sort of
at the next step in the,
in the logic process because you asked
about the relationship between these
frames with you know,
in relationship to one another and that
is the next issue.
It's like,
but responsibility and individuality,
but I'm curious about responsibility
implies a connection to other people.
Okay.
Well what are the things.
One of the things we are going to talk
about in the classes is how you address
the problem that you just described,
which is that this is the Peter Pan
Story.
Roughly speaking is Peter Pan is this
magical boy.
Pan Means Pan is the god of everything,
roughly speaking,
right?
And so it's not an accident that he has
the name Pan and he's the boy that won't
grow up and he's magical.
Well,
that's because children are magical.
They can be anything.
They're nothing but potential and Peter
Pan doesn't want to give that up.
Why?
Well,
he's got some adults around them,
but the main adult is captain hook.
Well,
who the hell wants to grow up to be
Captain Hook?
First of all,
you've got to hook second year a tyrant
and third,
you're chased by the dragon of chaos
with a clock in its stomach,
right?
The crocodile.
It's already got a piece of you.
Well,
that's what happens when you get older.
Time has already got a piece of you and
eventually it's going to taste for you
and eventually it's going to eat you.
And so hook is so traumatized by now
that he can't help but be a tyrant.
And then Peter Parent looks at
traumatized Herc and says,
well,
no,
I'm not sacrificing my childhood for
that.
So that's fine.
Except the ends up Kenya lost boys it
Neverland,
well,
Neverland doesn't exist and who the hell
wants to be king of the lost boys and he
also sacrifice is the possibility that
it held a real relationship with a woman
because that's Wendy Wright and she's
kind of conservative middleclass London
dwelling girl.
She wants to grow up and have kids and
have a life.
She accepts her mortality.
She accepts her maturity.
Peter Pan has to contend himself with
tinker bell.
She doesn't even exist.
She's like,
she's like the fairy of porn.
She doesn't exist.
She's the substitute for the real thing
and so,
but the dichotomy that you're talking
about,
it's very tricky because there's a
sacrificial element in maturation,
right?
You have to sacrifice the pleura
potentiality of childhood for the
actuality of a frame and the question
is,
well,
why would you do that?
Well,
one reason is it happens to you whether
you do it or not.
You can either choose your damn
limitation or you can let it take you
unaware when you're 30 or even worse
when you're 40 and then that is not a
happy day.
You see,
I people like this and I think it's more
and more common in our culture because
people can put off matt maturity without
suffering and immediate penalty,
but all that happens is the penalty
accrues and then when it finally hits it
just wallops you because when you're 25
you could be an idiot.
It's no problem.
Even when you're out in a job search,
it's like,
well,
you don't have any experience in.
You're kind of clueless.
It's,
yeah,
you're young,
you know,
it's no problem.
We can.
That's what young people are like,
but they're full of potential.
Okay,
well now you're the same person at 30.
It's like people aren't so thrilled
about you at that point.
It's like,
what the hell have you been doing for
the last 10 years?
Well,
I'm just as clueless as I was when I was
22.
It's,
yeah,
but you're not 22.
You're an old infant.
Right?
And that's an ugly thing and old infant.
So they.
The reason,
part of the reason you choose your damn
sacrifice because the sacrifice is
inevitable,
but at least you get to choose it and
then there's something that's even more
complex than that in some sense is that
the problem with being a child is that
all you are is potential and it's really
low resolution.
You could be anything but you're not
anything.
So then you go and you do adopt an
apprenticeship,
roughly speaking,
and then you become at least you become
something and when you're something that
makes the world open up to you again,
you know,
like if you're a really good plumber,
then you ended up being far more than a
plumber,
right?
You ended up being a good employer.
Not,
not that plumbers are not putting
plumbers down.
It's like more power to plumbers.
They've saved more lives than doctors.
So hygiene,
right?
So you know,
if you're a really good plumber,
well then you have some employees.
You run a business,
you,
you make you,
you train some other people,
you enlarge their lives.
You're kind of a pillar of the
community.
You have your family.
It's you can,
once you pass through that narrow
training period which narrows you and
constricts you and develops you at the
same time,
then you can come out the other end with
a bunch of new possibility at help at
hand and young talked about that,
a thought that the proper part of the
proper path of development in the last
half of life was to rediscover that
child that you left behind as you were
apprenticing and so then you get to be
something and regain that potential at
the same time.
Very,
very smart.
Well,
he was very,
very smart.
That's very wise,
very wise thing to know,
so yep.
Sacrifice.
We'll talk more about that too.
You get to pick your damn sacrifice.
That's all.
You don't get to not make what your
sacrificial whether you want to be or
not.
That's a good thing to know as well.
So even though it's rather,
you know,
it's rough thing to figure out,
but other questions
I have
no one else.
Okay.
That thing you just said about noticing
it more and more people live into their
20 [inaudible] yeah.
What do you think about that?
Where do you think that comes from in
terms of culture?
We live in,
think universities facilitate it because
you can go to university to not be
something instead of going to university
to be something and that's it's pleasure
island
and the price you pay for it,
especially in the U.
S is debt and you're enticed into it
because the administrators can pick your
pocket,
so they rob your future self while
allowing you to pretend that you have an
identity.
Right?
Very nasty and you can't declare
bankruptcy with your student loans in
the US,
it's indentured servitude and it is
precisely pleasure island.
It's exactly that.
And so tuition fees of short way out of
control and part of the reason that
universities don't make more demands on
their students and let them get away
with all the things.
They let them get away with it because
they're basically,
why the hell would you chase them out?
There are $100,000
or more so they can do whatever they
want as long as you get to sell them to
the salt mines.
Right.
So,
and you know,
it's not the only reason because the
other thing that's happened is that the
rate of technological transformation is
so fast now and the rate of turnover of
things is that it's,
it is genuinely harder for people who
are say 18 to 20.
When I was a kid,
roughly speaking,
the kind of rough patch for,
for,
for life was probably 14 to 17,
something like that.
Now it's,
I think it's 18 to 25,
something like that.
And I think the reason for that is that
all the jobs that the bloody hippies
complained about being doomed to in the
19 sixties have now disappeared.
Their problem was,
oh my God,
I'm going to have to work for a
corporation and get a salary for the
rest of my life,
you know?
And then I'll just end up in with a
pension and that'll be my whole life.
It's like,
well,
it seems like a lot better deal than an
endless round of part time starbucks
jobs.
So,
you know,
some of it is that it's,
it's just,
it's,
there is a space now in our culture
that,
that is lacking for people to make that
transformation from,
from adolescence into adulthood.
And so it's just,
it's,
it's the cost of that is for stalled,
but it's not a good thing.
It's not a good thing
they're seeing this person's eft,
but I've heard about things.
Well,
the,
there's a couple of problems with the
degrees is that everyone has one.
That's the first one,
which.
So because scarcity matters obviously.
Um,
the second thing is,
is that the match between the degree in
the workplace has less and less self
evident.
You know,
what should happen when you go to
university is you should learn how to
think and formulate arguments.
You should learn to think,
speak and write.
That's what the humanities are for.
They're to make you dangerous,
right?
Because if you can think and speak and
write your deadly in a complex job,
you're exactly what's necessary.
But if you don't have that,
it's like what the hell good is the
degree.
So I mean,
a degree in English literature doesn't
prepare you for a job,
it could make you think,
write and speak,
which prepares you for any complex job
and that's what's supposed to happen.
But increasingly I think that doesn't
happen
and the employers are waking up to this
very rapidly.
So,
and they're,
I mean,
they've already known that most for most
complex positions,
they have to train their people.
Now they're thinking,
well,
why do I have to bother with the degree
if I'm going to train them,
if it isn't bringing anything of value?
You see this.
And even fields like law.
When I went to do a debate at Queen's
university three weeks ago,
I think they couldn't get anybody to
debate me.
You know,
they,
the guy had to pay,
play devil's advocate.
We were talking about bill [inaudible].
And I thought,
Jesus,
that's so pathetic.
I'm talking about legal matters.
And I meant the world greatest.
One of the greatest universities in the
West,
you know,
I mean,
it's in the top 200,
let's say.
Um,
I couldn't get someone to argue with the
stupid psychology professor about law,
had to get a devil's advocate.
And so one of the things that was really
disheartening talking to the students
was they told me four or five of them,
they're not learning a damn thing in
law.
It's all social justice nonsense.
So like,
well good,
that'll do it in the profession.
It's being done in any ways because
lawyers being replaced by automation.
And so a lot of what they do is dig up
information.
It's like,
well you can do that on your own.
And forms are proliferating like Matt.
So the law school should be teaching you
to be a monster.
You better be,
but you come out,
you're concerned with social welfare.
Oh God.
It's like,
well,
there's just nothing to that.
It's like you can come out and say
you're,
you want to be nice to people.
Well that's nice.
Good.
You go right ahead.
Just like I'll go find someone who can
do something and you can go be nice to
people and see how effective that is.
So it's a lot of things that are
conspiring in the same direction.
People don't have to get married to have
sex,
so we have no idea what that's going to
do.
Although we know one thing it's done is
the only people that get married now or
rich.
Right.
Which is another thing that's really
comical because the feminist idea in the
sixties was that marriage was an
oppressive,
patriarchal institution.
It's like,
okay,
fine.
Then why do only rich women get married
now?
Because that's.
That is the case.
And so for poor women,
the dissolution of marriage has been an
absolute catastrophe.
They are so screwed because they have
kids.
So they're working,
they've got their 90 hour work week,
man,
that's for sure.
They're much less attractive to
potential.
So they get low quality men,
often parasitical and predatory.
So they often have like jobs in retail
for example,
which are just dreadful.
You don't even know what your schedule
is going to be.
You get paid hardly anything,
you know?
It's really.
But if you know,
most of the women who,
who,
who are outspoken feminists are on the
successful end of the associate economic
distribution.
There are university students or people
like that,
they don't even know any poor women,
so they have no idea what their lives
are like and you would never know
because they're at home working,
you know,
they're either at their horrible job or
they're at home slaving away with their
kids.
So it's not like they're out there
telling you what's wrong with them.
So
fix this Ita.
So sometimes he listed it as a lack of
critical thinking and language.
It's almost like it's like a logic
association with punctuation of herbs
and it feels sometimes they're lacking
in this basic knowledge.
Just put two and two together.
The best way,
the best way to teach people critical
thinking is to teach them to write.
And I made this little thing that I put
online.
It's,
I don't know if maybe it is it in the
site for 34 website.
Did I post that rubric for Essay
Writing?
I don't think it actually went through.
I think it is still on 4:30.
That's fine.
Is it not on for 34?
Is that not working?
Oh yeah,
it's still in corporate before 30.
Oh,
okay.
Well there's an essay.
Hope that's too bad.
It's not on the site for 34 website even
because I updated it anyways.
I have this guide to writing this that
if it isn't on the 4:34
website,
it is definitely on the 4:30
website and it steps people through the
process of writing because what's
happened now,
it's very hard to teach people to write
because it's unbelievably time intensive
and like writing marketing a good essay.
That's really easy.
Check a.
You did everything right,
right.
Marketing a bad essay.
Oh my God.
The words are wrong.
The phrases are wrong.
The sentence is wrong.
They're not ordered right in the
paragraphs.
The paragraphs aren't coherent and the
whole thing makes no sense,
so trying to tell the person what they
did wrong.
It's like,
Whoa,
you did everything wrong.
Everything about this essay is wrong.
Well that's not helpful either.
You have to find the few little things
they did half right and you have to
teach them what they did wrong.
It's really expensive and so what I did
with this rubric was trying to address
that from the production side instead of
the grading side,
but the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tell students why they should write
something.
It's like,
well,
you have to do this assignment.
Well,
why are you writing?
you need the grade.
It's like,
no,
you need to learn to think because
thinking makes you act effectively in
the world.
Thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake and those could be battles for
good things.
If you can think and speak and write,
you are absolutely deadly.
Nothing can get in your way.
So that's why you learned to write.
It's like why not?
I can't believe that people aren't just
told that it's,
it's,
it's like it's the most powerful weapon
you can possibly provide someone with.
And I mean,
I know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life.
I mean those people,
you don't want to have an argument with
them.
They'll just slash you into pieces and
not in a malevolent way.
It's like if you're gonna make your
point and they're going to make their
point.
You better have your points organized
because otherwise you are going to look
like and be an absolute idiot.
You are not going to get anywhere.
And if you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation,
if you can speak to people,
if you can lay out a proposal,
God,
people give you money,
they give you opportunities,
you have influence.
That's what you were at university for.
And so that's what you do is you
urinate,
you're in English,
right?
You're in your new languages anyways.
It's like,
yeah,
teach,
teach people to be articulate because
that's the most dangerous thing you can
possibly be.
So,
and that's motivating.
If people know that,
it's like,
well,
why are you learning to write?
Because your,
here's your sword,
here's your [inaudible],
right?
Here's your bulletproof vest.
Like you're learn how to use them,
but it's just,
it's an endless mystery to me why that
isn't made self evident.
So
that's the sort of thing that can drive
you mad.
Trying to sort out.
It's like people are,
there's a,
there's a conspiracy to bring people
into the education system to make them
weaker.
So
I guess that keeps the competition down.
Maybe that's one way of thinking about
it.
If your students are stupid,
they're not going to challenge you.
So other questions,
disagreements.
I mean it's a pretty harsh indictment of
the university system.
You get depleted points that if you stay
a,
which is of course a really good point.
You,
you have mobile mobility solution,
right?
Yeah.
But then is also like April.
It's also assuming that you will always
get to a solution.
Yes,
true.
yes,
yes.
Analytic solution that will keep them
true.
Well,
you know,
there used to be,
before the divorce laws were really
liberalized,
there were there you could sue for
irreconcilable differences and sometimes
people do find themselves in that
situation.
It's like one person wants children in
the other person doesn't.
It's like that's a tough one.
It's a tough one to negotiate,
so I'm,
I'm certainly not saying that just
because you lock yourself into a,
like two cats in a barrel that,
that will make you solve your problems
because problems are hard to solve and
sometimes you can't solve them.
I was just pointing out what the cost
of,
of leaving the back door or what the
cost of leaving the back door open is
and it's a big cost and you know,
one of the things I see too is that
people's identities fragment
increasingly across time.
You know,
one of the things that you have as you
age is something like the continuity of
your life.
You know,
you,
you have someone that you're with,
you've tied your story together with
theirs.
You have children,
maybe they have children.
It's like there's this continual payoff,
so to speak,
in quality that you obtained from
staying within that frame and you can
jump out of that.
And I suppose to some degree that that
provides freedom,
but it isn't obvious to me that there
does that for people.
One specific relationship.
It's a email.
No,
but,
but it's also the case that sequential
relationships are unlikely to be that.
So look,
I,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not make,
I'm definitely not making a utopian case
for marriage.
I would like to hear the case for the
boys from you because he made a really
interesting,
right?
It says top points,
but at the same time I think there are
relationships that are one.
Yup.
And we,
if that's the case,
then insistent them a cannot be good.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's definitely the alternative
argument.
And of course there are strong things to
be said on both sides,
but see there's some,
there's some additional problems with
divorce that people don't really grasp
when they're young.
Like the idea that you can be divorced
once you have children.
That's kind of a stupid idea because you
can't,
you can,
you can find a limited substitute for
your initial freedom,
but if you,
if you have kids and you try to get
divorced,
the probability that that's going to
demolish your life is very,
very high.
First of all,
it's incredibly expensive.
So one or both of you is going to come
out of that poor and
your market value has declined.
Let's say you're the woman who takes the
kids.
Your market value has declined
radically.
You're going to be poorer.
The man,
he's just a screwed because he is now an
indentured servant and there's no escape
from it.
So it's.
And it's not so bad if you can negotiate
a peaceful separation and some people
can,
but lots of times if you have a terrible
relationship,
it's not like negotiating and peaceful
separation is all that easy,
but if you're at each other's throats,
good luck to you.
I think it's roughly equivalent to
having non fatal cancer.
It is not pleasant.
It's a 10 year process,
15 year process.
It'll cost you $250,000
and it'll tear a big chunk out of your
life and also it will really disrupt
your relationship with your kids.
And you know,
you bring kids into a step.
Parent family,
they do not do as well.
Step parents are not as good as parents,
as biological parents.
And the data on that is clear.
Now,
obviously there are exceptions because
there are terrible biological parents
and there are wonderful step parents,
but if you look in aggregate,
it's not that easy to care for children.
You need everything.
You can binding you to them and if
there's someone else's children,
mostly they get in the way of the person
that you love,
right?
Well,
if I'm,
let's say you have a child,
I'll be right out.
Let's say you have a child and I want to
go out with you every second you spend
with that child is the second you don't
spend with me and,
and there's gonna be a price for that.
I'm not going to be happy about that.
And,
and if I have a child,
you're going to feel exactly the same
way.
You might say,
well no,
I love children.
It's like,
yeah,
sure,
sure you do.
I doubt it.
You might love your child.
And,
and you know,
it's pretty specific the way that people
loved children.
So,
and the rate of abuse for kids in step
parent families is way higher than it is
in biological families.
There's not even any comparison.
So anyways.